there's no time
[Music]
the time is 13. o'clock
[Music]
hey everybody
it's wednesday and you know what that
means
it's time for the main show
man as soon as i turned the thing on but
i got a horrible ringing right in my ear
i don't know why that started all right
if you hear any kind of like uh thunder
and stuff like that uh yeah that's what
it is it's thunder yeah storm outside
like like i said it's florida y'all and
it's summertime this happens pretty much
every day sometimes earlier than this
florida monsoon season it is yeah so
hopefully the power stays on we haven't
had too much trouble with the power
going out it flashed off the other day
but
that's kind of his worst yeah reset
everything yeah that kind of sucked but
yeah this evening we have
strawberry daiquiris yeah went down and
made some i didn't realize that we still
had all that strawberry daiquiri mix
left
so
i was like well [ __ ] i thought we used
all that up
this glass it's too big for my tiny
little hands but yeah it looks white on
camera that's because it's [ __ ] it
frosted itself
it's all blended ice frosty yeah
yeah it's delicious you did it with the
immersion blender delicious
grantham said it's raining like cow piss
on a flat rock in michigan
i mean here it's not i don't think it's
raining yet i don't hear anything but i
hear thunder
i hear thunder though i'm trying to get
in the mood for this show man
well why so why aren't you in the mood
for i don't know just kind of a weird
day is it there rolling in it did a
weird day
i don't know i've been kind of pissed
off because they're trying to verify my
id so i can talk to the va
and the [ __ ] ai is [ __ ] up i just
don't want to talk about that [ __ ] man
[ __ ] i had to send them photographs all
my documents and then they send me links
no you gotta you gotta follow this link
and this is just no man their [ __ ]
doesn't work
and i'm at the i'm at the very end
i gotta call them and do a video call
so you can see my face yeah and i get my
[ __ ]
i get my uh
my verified identification online
identification so i can access my va
records and uh fill out prescriptions
that's all it is oh i've been fighting
this [ __ ] for three days to become
verified
well you know technology
i have similar problems
with various technological things had to
take a picture of my [ __ ]
both sides of my
driver's license social security card i
think you're gonna save both sides of
your head no in the front of your head
back your head here's my ass when i see
my ass too and then both sides my birth
certificate
bert certificate b-e-r-b-e-r-t
your burton certificate birth
certificate
that's what they are in mississippi they
have a birth certificate your birth
certificate
what's that bert
yeah all right well no i know well like
i said dude i deal with like technology
and computers and [ __ ] like that like
every day so every day is like a
huge headache of frustration well plus
like most of my [ __ ] not so much this
laptop this is like pretty new and this
this is the laptop that i pretty much
only use for streaming that's all i use
this for so i don't have too much
trouble with this but like everything
else like i have another computer that's
for
video editing and then i have one that's
for graphic design and those are kind of
old and so a lot of the [ __ ] can't be
updated and it's just kind of like
there's all these kind of problems so i
understand tammy says she can 15 pipes
of salsa this morning
i got a whole wow yeah holy i got a
whole case of a damn bass
uh cannon jars they're about that size i
think they're a little bit shorter i
don't know if that might be two pints i
don't know i don't
i don't know how big they were they were
just big ones mmm salsa
yeah sounds good and i got a bunch of
lids a bunch of ceiling lids just that
it could go on jars like that it's a
real kind of
common lid size
got two of them two boxes of those so
you know
some of these jars i can turn into
canning jars
start canning stuff out of that garden
jarring it
that's a good idea yeah what all is out
there today
i haven't looked
i got five eggplant we're getting ready
to come in
more eggplant again yeah too
eggplant just keeps rolling
oh
a couple of green peppers
bell peppers yeah okay yeah i thought
we'd i thought we'd tomatoes are shut
down for a while
no i think
about another month or so they'll start
coming back maybe two months i gotta
check again
but the plants are good they're just not
yielding um
they kind of go through a little cycle
and then um
let me see
i got some potatoes coming
oh okay maybe another couple weeks i'll
check on them
potatoes and then um
the two banana trees
uh
i had to give them a drink of water
they're not
they're not really looking that good
they look thirsty
we'll see
you guys i don't want my banana trees
dying
i went out bought two banana trees these
are the actual bananas these are the
ones that not just not not just the
ornamental but yeah they actually make
bananas they actually make bananas but
there won't be any bananas not like the
sexless banana trees that just have
pretty leaves
[Laughter]
and i got a lemon tree out there that i
can bury but that's after the season's
over
oh barry that's got a bunch of lemons on
it but they're all green
well don't i mean
generally citrus is a winter is it not
yeah it's not it's not ready to to plant
though
i think it said planted in winter
that's what i'm saying
because i know like because i'm from
florida and like oranges and grapefruits
and [ __ ] like that that's when you'd
harvest that [ __ ] in like wintertime
um hugo says the only reason i watched
the mummy four is because of the
terracotta warriors i mean when you
think about it
like i kind of feel like everybody knows
about the terracotta warriors but like
when you were looking at them and like
when i was doing research for the show
i'm like this is really
[ __ ] amazing looking i mean it's a
massive massive
complex yeah and i mean a lot of people
were involved it was kind of like an
assembly line thing but it's like still
every single one of those warriors like
looks a little bit different like they
all look individual and probably after a
dude they probably represent an
individual soldier
yeah i mean they had a bunch of
different i i think we'll get into it a
little bit later but i think they had
like about 10 different molds yeah
and then and then they would kind of
like mix and match and then like but
after they would make the face in the
mold like from one of the 10 different
molds and then they would use like some
clay to like make different little
facial features so everybody would look
different so they actually were
individual but the bodies like the legs
and stuff like that those were mostly
mass-produced although they're all
different heights though yeah so you
know they're reproduction they're
reproductions of the soldiers that were
on duty at the time they went down there
was like taking a picture you just sit
there well i don't know about that
because the thing because it took like
almost 40 years like to build all of
those and the thing like that you know
but it probably just did the faces at
the last part or you know what i mean
yeah maybe maybe they did all the bodies
first or you signed a contract you know
do you agree that after death your soul
will [ __ ] come to this statue and
stay on guard oh yes i'll do it okay
then they [ __ ] put your face on it
you know kind of like a scientologist in
their [ __ ] ten thousand year [ __ ]
contract it's like that
i kind of feel like it's good to you
they were using these are the chinese
man they're not bullshitting they have i
kind of have a system behind it i kind
of feel like it probably would have been
a thing like hey you want your face on a
terracotta warrior you got to pay like
this much money
and then we'll put your face on there
no but i thought i think that would be
funny it'd be funny but that's not
that's not a chinese thought and that's
not how that's not how militaries think
they were some kind of royal guard and
they were like elite soldiers and it was
probably a [ __ ] great honor to be in
that unit
and at some time in your service and
like you said that their service
probably went on for 40 years
across generations of people that were
in that unit you know i mean like 101st
was [ __ ] around for a hundred
something years you know
so probably just your best guys got
selected to serve in that unit in the
afterlife you know it's probably some
kind of reward
and uh you know you said yeah i'll go
and then when it was come time to make
that make a statue they'd
or they probably maybe drew you
just to see what you look like and then
when it came time to make the statue
they would just do it to specification
they were real organized super organized
so that you know they probably just had
his
likeness kind of
codified into what
basic face what basic mouth what basic
nose and eyes and then they probably
would just draw slight differences and
go yeah that's [ __ ] wu-tang you know
okay [ __ ] so then when it comes time
to make his statue they just
went by the drawing and the order placed
an order for it you know
what chin what nose just and then by the
time you made it that dude was probably
dead anyways yeah so it's not like
anybody would be like hey that doesn't
look like ham yeah that's possible
by the time but his was probably on
record his face and what it would look
like and how to how to codify it into a
code that they could
reproduce on these statues and it was
probably just kind of a symbolic
likeness you know what i mean
yeah because i feel like it would have
been because
yeah i i kind of feel like for a long
time because i i think as far as i know
there's what how many have they
unearthed now like almost 8 000 of those
things um and it's not just soldiers
either we'll get into that later it's
worse than chariots and there's
acrobats they're all kind of [ __ ] in
there it's the whole army
well it's army and it's other things too
it's like entertainers that's the army
too because yeah that's what i mean so
it's like you went with all those guys
it's all kind of different uh figures
that was their tv set they didn't have
tv yeah like we had so you had to bring
all the entertainment the uso came with
you
yeah that's what it was
but yeah so i kind of feel like you know
it would have been
amazing if they'd been able to do
all of those sculptures like
individually but they didn't actually
they did it all like
you know like like like an assembly line
like i said it was just like you know
they made the legs and they made like
the body parts and stuff and then the
heads were just kind of like more
individualistic but they did them piece
by piece and then assembled them
afterwards i was looking at those faces
though you know i've seen them and
those were dudes
i'm pretty sure the way the chinese
would think and the the kind of thinking
that they would use the organization
they had real good science a lot better
than people thinks you know they were
messing with steam power and [ __ ] maybe
not in this particular period but then
later on they were
by the time the 1300s were around 1200s
i think they had steam ships
i mean there was [ __ ] well i think you
can only dream of in the west they were
they were dealing with it i mean but you
know that like the terracotta warriors
are like from
like yeah 210 blake bc yeah yeah they're
but they're like thousands of years old
yeah but they already had [ __ ]
fantastic technology they were good real
good
there was
the thinking is very modern
to what they're doing in terms of how to
produce something else mass but we'll
get into it
what's up dave hey yeah dave's here but
you know the ancient egyptians were good
too yeah you know
well like i said companies that built
those pyramids that's why like kind of
going off on a little bit of a thing but
it's like that's why ancient astronaut
kind of stuff kind of sort of pisses me
off so much yeah it's because because
i'm like you're really discounting the
ingenuity and intelligence of like
ancient people who were not dummies you
know they figured [ __ ] out there was
[ __ ] going on in the greek golden age
that we will never understand you know
[ __ ] uh they were dealing with
machines and their stuff like the
antiquathera mechanism that was during
the the roman period
i think that was around what [ __ ] 100
bc maybe 200
a.d around that period i can't remember
but
this antikythera device
fell off of a ship and they found it
down the bottom of the ocean it was just
this damn machine
to
predict where stars would be up in the
constellation and a bunch of gears and
cogs it was a mechanical computer
and people have looked at that and just
were [ __ ] amazed
handmade mechanical computer
with
cog wheels and perfect you had to be
really good at mathematics in order to
make that thing production was [ __ ]
beautiful
and
nothing like that could have been made
um
up and that we know of up until the
1920s
and this shit's [ __ ] ancient and they
were doing stuff that we could only do
into the in the twenties
better than a damn clown they figured
[ __ ] out they were real good they were
real smart
well the thing too is that they didn't
have a lot of other distractions like we
have in modern life well they had some
geniuses you know
uh archimedes he was well documented
genius who accidentally killed by the
romans they were looking for him
in the middle of a damn war and a
soldier killed him a roman soldier
killed him
and i don't know if if they knew that it
was archimedes or if it was an accident
but they're like well god damn it but
even the romans were pissed that it was
a great loss to mankind because he could
just
make steam engines and
mechanical computers and physics and it
was starting to understand physics and
geometry
how to measure
the mass of you know like the mass by
volume and you know it was just real
smart
and um
didn't have universities you just had
tutors you know
tutors and books which works that says
systems like that work
um
you don't really need universities
unless you're dealing with a
with a what do you call it
a an industrial society where you need
lots of educated work work people all at
once then you need universities
but other than that you can just have
hangouts with just a bunch of experts
teaching other experts
but you're going to end up mostly with
philosophy and geometry and mathematics
is what they were big into poetry songs
music
and uh you know
rich people rich kids went
and you know
if you could afford a [ __ ] badass
tutor he could come to your house and in
a matter of four five six years maybe
you'd know everything he knew
which that's a good way of doing it
oracle says i love that archimedes was
busy with his geometry when he was
murdered don't disturb my circles
reportedly his last words
yeah don't [ __ ] up my circles man what
the [ __ ]
yeah the only reason why it didn't go
industrial really and back in the
ancient days is that there was there was
no need for labor saving devices
that was the problem
if they need labor-saving devices they
you'd probably had an industrial
revolution but
they were in sourcing all the damn labor
to slaves
dramatic slaves and stuff making them
till soil
so you didn't need anything labor saving
technology was only used in places where
you could make money and all the money
was being made in temples
so you ended up with things like moving
statues and
clocks that controlled doors and
automatic music makers and
[ __ ] like that that coin operated holy
water dispensers it's just not a joke
they had yeah i know
but that made that's where the money was
and really you know temples were
kind of like the nightclubs
and the of the era
they're more like entertainment i think
than anything else
entertainment and partying
because they were taking drugs and
drinking and singing and dancing
watching shows and
having sex and [ __ ] depending on what
cult it was and then they had
cult
man i'm getting way off track but cult
what
else cult prostitutes and [ __ ] well what
we're talking about here is a rave
you know essentially what's what you're
talking about is a rave yeah some of
them were about drinking breast milk and
[ __ ] so it's a fetish club now okay it's
a goddess that you drink from her foot
milk from her breasts
and then all these pregnant women
[ __ ] squirting and everything this is
[ __ ] lactation fetish okay yeah it's
like they have whole websites yeah
that's what we're talking about
so
they weren't as dumb as they were
thousands of years ahead of their head
they weren't as dumb as you think they
were
well it's not so much that it's just
that
you know there's only i mean humans only
operate within a set of certain set of
parameters it's a pretty wide set i'll
give it that but
i mean you can't really think of
anything that hasn't been thought of at
some in some way shape or form before
you know you can think of a new take on
it but it might not be as new as you
think it is humans have been around for
a long time thinking and they're
basically unchanged like uh you hear a
lot of a lot of [ __ ] philosophy and
[ __ ] about progress and [ __ ] we're not
progressing we're
it's a cycle it's about the same
um
the future is not gonna look like
[ __ ]
the jetsons and [ __ ] it's not going to
look like even what h.g wells thought
although it kind of looks like the
jetsons now we have a lot of stuff that
the jetsons have so it's not that crazy
to think that but if you look at history
you know it's [ __ ]
[ __ ] i guess you could probably go back
almost 6 000 years
and uh you have an idea kind of what
happened
uh civilizations don't last long they
kind of go through it well and then you
say well how do you define a
civilization
there was always kind of
technological
growth kind of would stagnate and then
go up and then go back down and grow up
but people were generally kind of the
same and
i think the future is going to look a
lot like the past
but they'll have technology
eventually i think it'll just look like
what you saw in dune
the old dude it'll be
monarchs and warlords
with technology [ __ ] spaceships and
[ __ ] but it's probably like that
warrior cults religious cults running
[ __ ]
um
[ __ ] like banning ai all that's just
very plausible frank hubert [ __ ]
thought about that they had ai but it
enslaved them and they rebelled against
it in the butlerian jihad you know took
a long time as men being controlled by
machines that were controlled by men and
men controlling machines and just that's
[ __ ] pretty cool that you you doubt
shout not make an a machine in the image
of the mind of man you do that [ __ ] then
you die they kill you for that
murder hornet said ancient romans drew
dick pics on walls all the way back then
yeah it's true well i get well when they
uh unearthed um uh pompeii
they found all kind of like uh porn on
the walls
yeah that was necessarily porn all the
time though they no not porn but i'm
just like you know what i mean
we should we have an arrow go go this
way on the sides street sides they had a
dick yeah and it would point man go that
way dick says go that way
[Laughter]
they had a sense of humor i guess i had
a sense of humor it goes that way well
they were very dick centric goes that
way it's like why draw an arrow when you
can draw a penis yeah
i mean you know it was about masculine
power it's like she goes that way
i imagine you get you follow that dick
and they had chug nuts but it was nuts
and a dick hanging out on the front of
your chair your carriage yeah emperor
come down which is hilarious dude i love
that they had truck nuts like yeah
that's back there yeah big little dick
and nuts i'm sure they didn't really
call them that but well they probably
called them like the ancient roman
equivalent yeah
yeah because they had like a lot of like
little dirty [ __ ] yeah you you had
that [ __ ] hanging out on the front when
you were having your triumph back in
[ __ ] rome you know after after you
were awarded something that's right look
at the size of the deck on that man
that's right it's funny you know i think
they had a good sense of humor that's
hilarious
i did have a memorial to a dude would be
an obelisk with his [ __ ] head and
shoulders right there in his name and
when he what he did and his [ __ ] all
and his looking accomplishments and when
he died everything like that and then
underneath it rather be a statue of his
dick yep so just so you could not well
and i loved it
that the the show rome and the show
spartacus shows that shows that yep and
i was like that's really good they got
that accurate that's right because it's
like they didn't i kind of feel like a
measure of a man like a long time ago
when they made stuff about ancient rome
they kind of cleaned it up a little bit
yeah yeah so i kind of like that they've
gone back to us like no this is what
ancient rome was actually like they were
like really swore and it's like yeah
they actually had the statue was like
here's the guy and here's all his
accomplishments and here's his penis
yeah it was just like that's what he was
putting on like a stone
yeah that's what you do so i like that
they put that on the show because i'm
like oh okay accurate but you know they
cheated
if you're [ __ ] sitting he's like well
of course come on help me out a little
bit
yeah because yeah i mean if you had like
you know god forbid you had like a micro
dick or something like that but you
still like got to like a you know
through your intelligence or whatever
right yeah and you're just like bro come
on yeah yeah help me out a little bit
yeah
well you're paying him to do the stats
that's what i'm saying like you're the
one that's paying you're like come on
just like you know i imagine this is for
posterity i would imagine there's a lot
of dick propaganda
yeah
well it's not like anybody that's paying
for a statue like that is gonna have
their dick be smaller right i mean
they're always gonna have a bee beggar i
mean i said it especially you're not
gonna be able to check they're dead
that's what i'm saying yeah so that and
that's probably what they thought it's
for posterity they're like you know a
hundred years from now people are gonna
be like woo look at the member on that
fella you know what i mean so it's just
kind of it's like no one's gonna know no
one took a picture of it he didn't send
dick pics to people over [ __ ]
instagram or whatever yeah
you know i think you're supposed to
stand for that kind of [ __ ] for the
sculpting part they probably drew it
first because it'd be easier
yeah because you don't want like to
stand you have to stand there like yeah
it probably while somebody sculptured it
down from a drawing of your face and
your dick first i wonder did they i
wonder did they just like coat it in
plaster like that you could probably do
that too but then that would be you
well yeah it didn't like uh cynthia
master blaster caster plaster what was
her name remember she was that she was
that groupie that like followed all
those bands around she was an artist and
she did all those uh
plaster casts of like dudes uh
crotcheler areas yeah
grampar says there are some black
churches in detroit where they have
swinger parties and get all drunk and
doink
okay
hey that's what they want to do that's
what they want them to do what do you
want to do man mrs evans already party
says charitas not a miss maximus
tammy said on a totally different topic
i saw something that said they might
have proof the three guys that escaped
from alcatraz might have gone to brazil
to live i heard something about that
just the other day
what was that i was watching something
about escape from alcatraz or i saw it
like on some other thing and they said
yeah they think those dudes might um
might have like lived might have
survived they never found their bodies
right i kind of been wanting to do a
show about escape from alcatraz but i
put it in the patreon poll a bunch of
times and it never wins that would be
the place to go because in that era they
don't think brazil had extradition
and it would be an easy it's easy to me
i lived there you know so it'd be easy
to for americans to live there
especially in that era brazil was doing
good be like running into argentina back
when argentina was good
i know there was another bank robber
that ran down there
i think it was in the 60s
60s or the 70s and he was famous in
brazil for being a bank robber he lived
in the favela though he didn't have any
money
but he got married what happened to all
the money that he stole from the bank
spin it all up probably dummy you didn't
you don't think he spent a lot i mean i
thought the whole point of like doing
like a big bank heist was like that so
you wouldn't have to do it again i mean
get enough the first time so you can
like disappear and retire and live the
rest of your life without dudes live
large for a few years and [ __ ] blow
all their money that's idiotic don't do
that kind of [ __ ] they do
and plus it it makes you more uh you
know vulnerable to getting caught by the
lock so like hey why does this
[ __ ] suddenly have all this
money and he's doing like throwing money
around well it didn't matter in brazil
because he he told he told everybody who
he was
there was no extradition hi i'm a bank
robber yeah yeah i said second bankrupt
he had the money but they couldn't
extradite they didn't have an
extradition treaty back
then remember when that i remember
seeing
articles of him
back in the 80s he had been there for a
long time 20 years maybe
maybe 30 years it might have happened in
the 50s but he was an old man in the
article
yeah oracle brings up uh for that matter
look at the cod piece yeah that was
another thing that was a yeah that was
middle ages like early middle ages like
trying to like puff out the a lot of
that stuff
a lot of that stuff you know like from
europe like the those italian statues
that the church made and like you know
michelangelo looking stuff yeah somebody
she brought that they had these little
[ __ ] micro dicks and [ __ ]
well that's not quite a micro dick but
it's pretty small yeah the thing is that
was the church behind that they
they'd see this [ __ ] dude packing in
the church and get kind of [ __ ] they
they would commission the statue half
the time
and they were like oh well i don't know
that looks awful sexy can we make it
smooth like and
this is classic you know this and that
this is a good no it's nude this is a
greek statue and they're like well can
you could you make it could you cover it
no
can you make it smaller yeah i'll make
it small so they started asking them to
make the [ __ ] smaller and smaller and
originally they weren't that small
but they were trying to trying to
minimize the dick
because everybody in church was getting
all horny looking yeah they're trying to
minimize the dick it's which is kind of
like the japanese
japanese make porn but then they
pixelate it that's not what they were
doing
oracle said let's face it men throughout
the ages have found excuses to show
their dick since yeah it's true
and then she said and throughout the
ages women have wished they could just
get a little foreplay or at least a nice
foot rub
[Laughter]
yep that's true
um uh let's see
she also says something i heard about uh
again recent is anybody else familiar
with a a he's at home
no no what did she say reportedly he's
at home was a dildo that the whalers
would whittle for their wives so that
when the whalers were at sea the wives
could entertain themselves
i mean i'd heard about them doing that
but i didn't know that it had a name
that's like really funny here you go
let's just
to keep you company while i'm away yeah
that's [ __ ] hilarious sounds like a
tail though
well they did have dildos back then i
mean they've had dildos since like the
ancient times it's probably just
something that women bought
well yeah i don't think i don't i don't
think some whaler made that for his wife
i don't think they did that yeah well
yeah somebody maybe they maybe they made
them and sold them like as a side gig
the story was probably that but probably
in real life it's probably not going to
work here honey play with this and they
don't like the milky way
well yeah you know
just give me a baby's arms this portrait
uh fourth round also says yes a british
criminal called ronnie biggs fled to
brazil after robbing a mail train in the
1960s that's who it probably was i
thought he was american that's probably
who it was
yeah it's kind of a heavy set guy from
what i remember he didn't have any money
when they did an article on him
he was living in the favela
oracle said the article i read showed a
photo of it the dildo uh and it's
obviously a dildo yeah i mean they've
they've found like dildos you don't
really see them in museums so much but
museums absolutely have them in their
collection they just don't put them on
display because you know they're from
all right it's a it's a family show
roman said the romans had romans had
some stuff that
but it you know
by today's standards would be [ __ ]
filthy
they didn't think they were that filthy
though because when they saw it they had
stories
religious stories that kind of went
along with it there was one thing that
happened
where some noblemen
were sitting around having this
this is think it's in the 1500s maybe
1600s
they paid to have this excavation
done in this area
to find roman stuff
and they found a roman statue of
something
and as they were uncovering it they went
and they got the
the royal family you know the noble
family and all their friends they've
been paid for the excavation they're all
standing around it
while they're slowly uncovering it and
it's a man
and then they see it's a man his face is
up he's got a beard and [ __ ] doesn't
keep going and going and all of a sudden
there's a goat
yeah and it's just going to go and going
and what it is it's a seder yeah
screwing a [ __ ] female goat he's got
it by its [ __ ] back legs they're like
amazing oh yeah
they all [ __ ] went oh it's just
exciting i've seen it though i saw a
documentary about it i think it's um it
might be in the british museum
collection now i don't think there's
that was the only one i think there were
a lot of them yeah but i think the one
you're talking about i think is maybe in
the british museum's collection they
don't usually put it out i think they
have put it out on display like um for
kind of special events and stuff but
it's actually quite a beautiful statue
yeah it's [ __ ] quality is really good
it's gorgeous yeah but it's yeah it's
obviously basically a dude [ __ ] a
goat so well it's not a dude it's a
seder well yeah so it's a mythological
man beast
performing an act of bestiality on a
[ __ ] goat
and uh fun the the noble class couldn't
take it they're like oh no oh man they
clutched their pearls and headed for the
fountain patches
but there was some kind of roman story
that went along with that it was
religious there was i remember reading
it a long time ago but i can't remember
what the particular they didn't have the
context they didn't know what it was
they were looking at
yeah they're just like oh it's just
porny and we can't have that but yeah
there was a lot of porny [ __ ] they were
but like i said there's a lot of horny
[ __ ] and and i think a lot of it in the
vatican
yeah well i think there's i mean pretty
much any any museum like of any size or
you know anything has
a [ __ ] ton of that stuff but they don't
usually put it on display because
they're like oh you know kids come in
here and we don't have we don't want
their parents to have to have awkward
conversations like that what is that
why is the seder
why does she go why isn't she's trying
to get away
raping her [ __ ] goat
and he's laughing
well this man just really really likes
this goat very very much
[Laughter]
little timmy yeah
[Laughter]
all right should we get to the what
should we get is there anything we got
to say anything we gotta plug thanks oh
okay i don't think so do you want to
plug into your other channels
well yeah i got two other channels now
okay i mean i kind of feel like
everybody knows i have been like putting
them in the community tab like on the 13
o'clock channel just in case but more
people need to go over there and
subscribe because the quicker you all
subscribe the more i can
like the sooner i can monetize the
channels which would be nice but yeah
the one i put up a while back which is
all horror stuff is uh scarce salon it's
horror like movies and books mostly and
um
there's also a true crime one called
crime immemorial
sorry
and uh i got a mug for it right there
that i made
and that one just has one video but i'm
actually putting up another video
tomorrow i'm gonna be putting up two a
week and it has like a website
crimeimmemorial.com which is all
written stuff about unsolved murders and
i'm gonna put new stuff up every day
so there's that
i don't know why i just like suddenly my
throat went all
like that like all dry like tickly
um so i want to kind of talk a little
bit about
uh the emperor who
commissioned
the terracotta army and you wanted to
talk about the tomb as well even though
they don't know a huge amount
about the rest of the tomb because
only like one percent of it
has been excavated
like they've dug out most of the
terracotta soldiers that they know of
like i said i think 7 500 8 000 at this
point yeah um there might be some more
but they haven't really gone too much
into like the the tomb itself or like
the mausoleum complex this is some
mystery [ __ ]
it's kind of like our underground
mysteries but it also gets involved with
paranormal stuff there's some paranormal
thinking involved with this
you know the chinese
um
always
well not always because now you know
communism got them not to believe in
anything that was [ __ ] spiritual
but uh traditional chinese
culture was very paranormal very
mystical you know they believed in
spiritual dimensions
uh spiritual monsters demons things like
vampires
uh afterlives and hells
and um
it was china was not unified someone
said well china's thousands of years ago
old not really
modern china is really kind of an
invention of the 1960s and 80s rather it
hasn't been around that long
before that time it was just a bunch of
warring states
swallowing each other up conquering each
other
so there was no unified china it was
just an era an area and then they uh
even in the 20th century they were going
through a big warlord period they made
some weird-ass guns by hand
not even knowing how to what a gun was
they were making them
things that looked like sights but you
couldn't look through them so they
didn't really know what sites were just
weird [ __ ] they just saw pictures of
things that copy it
with no training which is kind of a
testament to the genius of the chinese
they could just see a photograph of
something go that shoots and then just
based on a photograph not even really
understanding anything about guns try to
copy it
which i wouldn't have the balls to do it
and it worked kinda
you can look that up it's called the
guns of the chinese warlords on youtube
weird [ __ ] chinese mystery pistols that
you can search that you'll see some
stuff on youtube
so the chinese were always genius they
were a genius people
kind of stuck between different worlds
kind of like the greek world of
rationalism and uh
the chinese world of [ __ ] precision
and the [ __ ] weird
spirit world the chinese were always
very
precision oriented keeping records
numbers
making systems they were very systematic
about things
you know such a you know and and and
ancient chinese secrets steam power
ships
they would could think in large
volumes you know how to make massive
armies
big ships like zhang ha you know it had
had a big fleet of [ __ ] steam ships
[ __ ] went all the way to europe this
is back in the 1500s
you know long before we had same steam
ships they were ahead
fell behind and only in recent times
1800s you know they went through a cent
what they called a century of
century of shame i think is what they
called it where they were just backwards
and failing starving
cannibalism
in china
kind of like a warring states period too
so they're trying to make a comeback a
lot of the [ __ ] the chinese do today has
to do with that
century of humiliation they're trying to
make a comeback and they they're they
hold britain
responsible
but they've always been a
disciplined
calculating people
and this goes all the way back to this
first emperor of china i think is
usually what they call it
yeah i mean sharon d
or some people call i've heard it's
called him called a couple different
things but his plays on that sherwood d
it's actually
what i the most common like i said he
has like some different names but i've
heard it pronounced uh
chin sure
huang shin sure won't yeah something
like that yeah
but i'm not gonna say that every single
time right yeah or huang di wan di which
we'll get into like the wording of
that's not actually his name
that's a title yeah
but um yeah so we'll get into that but
that's the name that he's most commonly
known by yeah now some of us said well
he's not really the first emperor chad
he was just like one of the first real
badass notable warlords
because he did unify a couple a couple
of lands in china together but
everything evidently they didn't hold
together for very long
well yeah i'm gonna go i'm gonna get all
into that he's gonna get into that but
yeah i'm gonna get all into that but he
had this massive tomb complex with a lot
of mysterious [ __ ] that to this day is
still a mystery
when i was a kid they were talking about
digging into that tomb complex
it was supposed to have a
3d map of all the lands that he ruled
and all the water had been replaced with
mercury and it flowed through it like
the rivers
and there he was buried down in there
with his brides changed to the wall like
some [ __ ] out of conan and
badass tomb complex in there
they went and did a [ __ ] mercury test
and yeah it kind of generally
the mercury that's seeping up through
the ceiling and it goes through the
ground on the top of that mouth in
general does it does look like an
ancient map of
of the chinese conquered territory but
they don't know
i think they once tried to put a camera
down in there but i'm not sure how
successful that was
like i said they're very
they're afraid to go in there they're
kind of afraid to go in there for you
know danger reasons and also because
it's you know it's it's a massive
archaeological find and they don't want
to [ __ ] it up yeah if oxygen gets in
there it's going to destroy a lot of
stuff well and that's kind of happened
to a lot of the terracotta warriors and
honestly though some of the ones that
they first excavated as soon as they
unearthed them like they started to
deteriorate um and i think like
a little bit later they kind of like
figured out a way chemically to like
keep that from happening like to keep
air from sort of like [ __ ] up the the
terracotta but
prior to that like yeah a lot of women
sort of store it and i and i don't know
if a lot of people know this but the
terracotta warriors i mean as cool as
they look like you know all
that kind of uniform color uh they were
all brightly painted at one point
yeah and uh all the paint has obviously
like worn off over this because it's
been buried for like two thousand years
before anybody found it nobody even knew
it was there until the 70s
really strangely enough the chinese have
money and they have technology
they don't seem to be real curious about
that
sherwood burial chamber
well no they're all digging into it they
got like all kind of archaeologists over
there are they going to go in there
because well yeah they're talking about
going in there okay like they've done
like um all kind of like magnetic
residents and they're kind of like
trying to figure out where everything's
at and like the best way they can
approach it and okay good [ __ ] like that
about it yeah because you can have to
build an airlock and then dig the rest
of the way yeah
like i said they're they're just i think
their reluctance is more because well we
have to approach this the right way
right because we don't want to open it
up and everything [ __ ] up because it's
like a really loud you got to go in
there with in space suits
basically you need to build an airlock
go in there with a space suit dig using
spacesuits and machines
and then you'll go in there and you walk
around in there and bring in your own
atmosphere
you got to be worried about uv light
even light can destroy pigments so you
might want to go in there with some kind
of light magnification you go no light
at all
or you know some kind of an invisible
light
and to try to take pictures of things
because
you bring in some bright light it might
[ __ ]
destroy some of the pigments on the
walls there's gonna be pictures and [ __ ]
yeah
i think like i said that's what they're
worried about and i think that's why
they're kind of like being really
circumspect about it because they're
like well this is our only shot at doing
this you gotta do it right the first we
gotta do them right the first time so
that's why they're kind of like trying
to do so like i said they've been trying
to do stuff from like outside with like
you know magnetic kind of stuff just to
see where everything's at and it's like
try to figure out what's going on in
there so it's like they don't really
want to like just barge in there because
well the thing about the terracotta
warriors was that they were found by
accident yeah you know and then they dug
it all out and they were like holy [ __ ]
look at all of this here because you
know
no one really expected it to it's
rumored that inside that tomb complex is
a bunch of traps like some [ __ ] out of
indiana jones i have heard that yeah
that there's booby traps that you're
collapsing walls
[ __ ] ceilings that come down on you
boom like that you know stone blocks
that fall to seal [ __ ] off like i said
just like tomb raider right yeah and i
don't know if that's true but uh that's
there's probably years about that the
chinese were uh meticulous about that
kind of stuff
they were worried about grave robbery
now
evidently some of some have surmised
that they were going to be ever
everlasting ever burning
basically oil lamps in there lighting it
up and we know nothing lasts forever
but
they were gonna they might have had some
kind of lamp system burning [ __ ]
what they consider to be an internal an
eternal amount of [ __ ] fuel oil
i don't see how it's possible but the
chinese could think up so maybe some
natural i mean the thing about it is
that because they haven't really gone in
there to any great degree and because
they've excavated so much of the
terracotta warriors which to be honest
is quite amazing um i think i don't know
i do people's imaginations are going to
run away with them yeah some of this
metal work on this stuff
like the carriages and the things that
are on the horses and the weapons
looks like something from the 20th
century that's how good that metal work
is well a lot of the weapons were real
yeah and a lot of the chariots worked
yeah they were like working and they're
made out of like bronze and [ __ ]
brass and [ __ ] like that and this
the the work is
like
it looks modern it looks ultra modern
it doesn't look
crude and ancient i mean it's beautiful
well-made
just
it's made by hand but you would you
would never know it looks like it was
made by a [ __ ] every time i see
pictures of that of of just all the
compounds and like and how big it is
it's big as like a football field or
bigger and it's just
it just amazes me that somebody like
built all that yeah i mean not one
person obviously it was lots of people
but
i've i've seen like
the thing about it even wikipedia says
this says that oh it was like 700 000
people like over now i'm not talking
about like all at once because like i
said it took him like 38 years
to build this whole like mausoleum
complex
but um
i don't know i don't know if it was 700
000 people i've seen
some scholars are kind of like that's no
there's no way it's like there's
you know no city had that many people in
it at that time that they know of if
they said it was probably more like
fifteen thousand like fifteen thousand
dudes could probably do that like given
enough time and resources
so you don't really need to say that it
was a million dudes but i don't know it
might have been a million dudes quality
control the stuff that i looked at was
[ __ ]
immaculate quality control
the stuff that they were making was made
by hand and and
and it was art artist rendered stuff but
it looked like it was made by
million dollar industries it looked like
it was made by machines and computers
and lathes
like it was something that was [ __ ]
machined on a [ __ ] modern computer
generated late but it wasn't
they were just that good with dealing
with metal they were [ __ ] great
if you were to hand them a modern
assault rifle they'd look at that and go
oh we can make that they'd make it but
they'd make it by hand and be precisely
like an ak-47 or any ar-15
they didn't have aluminum
but they would just make it in steel or
bronze or brass but it would it would
look just like that
that's how good they were
they were good enough to do the
measurements and everything
by what based on what i saw they said oh
they could easily make something like a
1911 45 auto or a thompson submachine
gun that
they could make that by hand they were
good real good fourth down said they
need to send tom cruise in there he'll
figure it out yeah
[Laughter]
well somebody was talking about the uh
the third mummy movie earlier which we
reviewed not too long ago right and that
kind of has the terracotta because like
i said the terracotta army is very very
famous but as i said
that's just kind of like and they have
like a museum there now too you can
actually go and like stand next to the
things and like get your picture taken
and [ __ ] like that but
the um it's really kind of just like a
smaller part of this whole mausoleum
complex which they haven't really
delved into all that much
but like i said they'll get around to it
i think but they're just they want to
make sure they don't [ __ ] it up
so let's talk about
uh this emperor now like i said i'm and
i'm apologizing in advance because i'm
sure i'm gonna like butcher a lot of
these [ __ ] names
now this guy is usually known like i
said the way i heard it pronounced and
i'm like as close as i can pronounce it
uh was chin
huang all right that's how i heard it
probably she sure won't
yeah i always heard it as sharon d
well
but that's another title that's what i
mean he had like a bunch of different
names and like i said sometimes like
that's the most common one but sometimes
i see huang di as well which i'll get
into like the nomenclature a little bit
later because i thought that was kind of
interesting but like i said that's more
of a title that's not his actual name so
that's just but what just means first
emperor
yeah yeah like i said i'll get into it a
little bit now his name what he was
named at birth was just zhang
okay uh that's what he was named up with
like i said that was a that was still a
common name today yeah
now uh
so he was essentially just as an
overview like he was king of the chinese
state of uh chin
from 247 bce to 221 bce and then the
first emperor of a unified china from
221 bce to 210 bce and he ruled under
the name
the first emperor and like i said he
wasn't the first emperor ever he was
just the first guy that sort of unified
all of these
warring states into one thing and
codified a lot of things
uh you know making everything like uh
kind of all one thing
now at the time that he was born
china was like you said it wasn't one
thing it was a whole bunch of different
feudal states that were all
at war with one another as feudal states
tend to be
so uh you know just because it's
the most obvious thing to call it this
period of history is known as the
warring states period because of course
they were states they were warring it
was a warring states period
so they were constantly fighting now
uh so one was taking over another you
know how it goes
so by 260 bce um there were only kind of
a handful of holdouts left
um the others had been conquered taken
over like into larger warring states
but the state that zhang
was born into which is called chin
was kind of the biggest the most
powerful at that time
now at this point it was governed by
something that was called the legalist
philosophy which is one of kind of like
the
i think it's like five philosophies or
something like that um basically what
legalism is at least as far as i could
determine because it's kind of
complicated and i want to get too much
into it but it's kind of like
philosophically people who are like um
into like legalism the chinese
philosophy it's like human beings are
kind of like [ __ ] and are more
inclined to be selfish and do [ __ ] wrong
unless you really like crack down on
them and have really really strict laws
where everything is like really clearly
delineated and everybody knows what they
have to do and why they have to do it
and if they do something bad then like
the punishments are very harsh so like i
said it's kind of like an authoritarian
type of thing
um
so and they're basically saying well the
best way to operate [ __ ] is very very
strict laws let people
pursue selfish interests but only to the
extent that it is beneficial to the
state like um you know letting them do
agriculture warfare you know building
projects [ __ ] like that
um and then you have an administrative
system that
would give that you know you'd have like
um officials and stuff and they would
get like money and rank and stuff like
that but they had to be kind of like
crack down on two so they wouldn't
usurp the power of like the ultimate
ruler so in other words there was an
anti-bureaucracy mode they didn't want
them i mean they had beer yeah they had
bureaucrats but everybody was a very
very clearly delineated
system of rules and there wasn't any
kind of like this individual like
uh you know thing where it's like oh
we'll make exceptions or this that and
the other for like an individual right
now you're just talking about the system
of legalism well yeah well yeah i'm just
talking about yeah i'm just talking
about when that's the general term we
use legalism yeah that yeah i already
said that okay when you were here yeah
so that's kind of what was going on you
had like the warring states period and
uh the
the state that zhang was born into was
one that was run by that
um
although he was actually born in another
one in another state uh called zhao
now the reason that he was born there
was because his dad whose name was
zeshu
i'm not sure if i'm pronouncing that
right now he was a prince from chin
but he was a hostage in this other enemy
state
yeah um like because there was an
agreement between the two states and he
was just like i don't think they were
like doing nothing bad to him but no
they were like family yeah they would
like keep him they were keeping him
prisoner back in those days to keep the
peace you trade fabulous right family
members
sometimes it might involve marriage
sometimes it's just no give me your son
he can stay with me and that'll that'll
that'll ensure that you won't attack
that you won't attack yeah because my
kid's over there right so they're going
to break they did that
yeah they would do the same thing
usually they were treated real well they
were given the best education and the
food and lifestyle and [ __ ] because you
were expected to take his son also
so you had to treat his
usually there was like a veneer of
friendliness i would treat your son as
my son he will be my son too i'm his
uncle that kind of [ __ ] you know what i
mean just like that yeah
so yeah so that's why zhang was born
there because that's where his dad was
being like a hostage quote-unquote
now zechu his dad uh later went back to
chin where he was a prince of
with the help of this kind of rich
merchant guy that he knew his name was
lou buwai
and
lou boy
yeah or whatever yeah um and he
essentially became like prime minister
chancellor or something like that like
of chin
now
according to the story now nobody knows
if this is true but the legend is the
legend is that zhang who would later
become the emperor that we're talking
about today who built the terracotta
warriors
uh that he wasn't actually the son of
his dad like who everybody thinks his
dad is but
was
lou bouway's son
and the reason everybody says that is
because
zhang's
mother
was
lubuway's concubine or one of them
and then he gave her
to zhang's dad
like he did with concubines but do you
have other ones here have this one this
is like a gesture of good faith or
whatever
so
and the story goes that when he gave her
to
zichu she was already pregnant now
nobody knows if that's true or not but
that's the story
so
nobody knows if zhang was actually like
a legitimate birth or if this other guy
was actually his dad probably legitimate
yeah but you see you always got a
[ __ ] kind of
undermine a dude you're somebody you
know i mean oh you know that [ __ ] goes
on in even in in english his
english history a lot you know i mean
william the bastard and all that kind of
[ __ ] yeah
yeah coming william the conqueror but
you know you know questioning the
motherfucker's bloodline if you if
you're that much of a badass then we're
gonna start questioning your bloodline
you know they just just
he was probably legitimate that's what
i'm saying and i think a lot of scholars
think that too they're just like yeah
this legend persisted probably just
because after he died yeah like people
who didn't like him took questions so
we're kind of like trying to but the
thing about it is that he didn't really
like the confusions and when the
confusions came in it's like if he had
actually been illegitimate they
absolutely brought that up and they
didn't really so
they're kind of like questioning whether
that was a true story or not probably
not so yeah i don't i don't know if it
is but that's kind of like a really
common legend about his birth or
whatever the the the
the romans okay the romans had an
equivalent of that
after you were dead
and as long as
after you were dead and as long as not a
none of your ancestors were on the
imperial throne they'd start questioning
your sexuality
it wasn't whether or not you had a
boyfriend as whether or not you were
taking it into booty or not and that
happened a lot of times they're saying
oh yeah he was [ __ ] around that dude
and he was the female out of the out of
the [ __ ] yeah because they didn't
really have a problem as long as you
were the top as long as you were the top
you just weren't supposed to be the boss
you didn't really no no no no one
everyone wanted to nobody body wanted to
be the receiver yeah exactly
which is like it's like that to this day
it had to be the pitcher and not the
kids exactly is it this is to this day
you know i grew up in brazil you know
central south america still liked it the
[ __ ] heterosexual male is always at
the top of the [ __ ]
man [ __ ] pile okay
you can
they tell you
you could be gay you know they didn't
have anything against that it's just
that you were lower in the cast the male
caste system
now you could be gay but as long as you
were a top you had more respect than a
bottom
okay it's just because that's there was
a higher woman and women are way the
[ __ ] down though no no no women women
had good status too it was just a
different status it was just it was just
the men and women were kind of like two
parallel
[ __ ] two parallel civilizations that
had happened
you know but [ __ ] at the time but you
know of course
most of this these machinations are
straight guys
coming up with this and these are the
systems that we make you know what i
mean you're gonna be like we're at the
top
well yeah of course everyone else
[ __ ] of course whatever if we're
gonna make this up then you just keep
thinking that that's just
you know
you may know what i'm talking about and
everyone else just rolls our eyes at you
[Laughter]
i'm just okay
i'm just i'm just saying you know
well it's like my buddy toby you know
he's he's leather daddy he's the top
okay
he likes straight guys he wants to hang
out with straight guys and you know
he would go out with a straight guy if
he could but if he went out with him
then he wouldn't be straight anymore and
the [ __ ] the the
the status would go away so you know
what i mean
sometimes you know what i mean if you're
straight the gay guys might like you but
they'd lose respect for you if you
became gay they wouldn't like you as
much
they like it because you're straight you
know but it's a certain not all gay guys
are like that's a certain kind of gay
guys that are like that so complicated i
mean it's a complication you should you
should just like people that are cool
yeah well that's what i do
and not worrying about it otherwise
i don't take any of that hierarchy [ __ ]
that seriously i i think it's fun you
know what i mean um because if you don't
have that as a backdrop then you live in
a world of chaos
but it's there's rules but i don't care
about breaking the rules i just like to
know what the default rules are you know
what i mean
i feel more comfortable with that and i
think a lot of a lot of other guys are
like that too
that they like to at least default rules
so they know when they're breaking the
rules or not
you know i'm talking about yeah i know
what you're talking about yeah yeah
murder hornet confucius say he who stand
on toilet is high on pot you know what
you know what my dad and my grandfather
were super into those confucius say
jokes i can't really remember any of
them
but
i feel like my dad used to say this all
the time kanabasana said hell yeah i
agree
well i don't know if he's what he's
agreeing with he's saying because
dude that's some toxic masculinity it is
yeah yeah see can you imagine like
thinking so much of yours although i
will add
and this was what i was going to say
earlier and i think you went off on a
tangent i forgot yeah but um
i will add that they think that the
reason
that uh that jang here
built this massive complex and all of
these soldiers
was because he was one he was scared to
death of dying which we'll get into in a
little bit
two he was afraid that everybody he had
conquered in life was gonna come kick
his ass in the afterlife exactly and so
he needed these soldiers to like protect
him in the afterlife so it wasn't so
much badassery or ego as being a chicken
[ __ ] and thinking everybody's gonna cup
kick his ass after he dies well it
depends on how you
he he thought he was at war and life so
therefore when he got into the spirit
world he would have to continue the war
to protect himself against his enemies
because they were over there too waiting
for him yeah he thought it would be yeah
logical assumption it is yeah it's not
weird to think that it's not really not
going to the afterlife they're all going
to be waiting they're all going to like
come again so yeah we're going to have
to fight him over there too
so i'm going to need life follow me
and we will go to the final victory
we'll [ __ ] whip ass we'll take over
heaven
okay
and that's the how the chinese would
think we'll take over heaven when we get
there
and the the the soldiers were like well
yeah of course
we took over here we're going to take
over over there
you know yeah i'll serve you over there
and then we'll run heaven
because there would he didn't have
judeo-christian concept of that there
was a supreme god in charge of heaven
heaven was just another dimension
well and it's
and i kind of feel like it's from time
to memorial like humans have
kind of like extrapolated our experience
here on earth into the afternoon well
it's going to be like that but more yeah
or slightly different but there but it's
essentially the same same thing because
that's what your experience is right so
you're just going to like kind of
exaggerate that experience that's why
i'm saying those terra cotta soldiers
that she's going to tell you about their
faces are different because they
represented [ __ ] real soldiers
that died
they were going to serve the emperor in
the afterlife
probably some reward
to be the emperor of soldiers in heaven
because you're going to take over heaven
you'll be war lords in heaven
that's quiet that's which sounds about a
badass mission
we yeah after i die here i'm going to
i'm going to go to heaven and [ __ ] me
and sherwood he's been dead 20 years but
we're going to link up we're going to
link up we're going to [ __ ] continue
the war over there i'm old here but over
there i'll be young again and we'll all
go back to work that's what they're
doing
got to say olejiang didn't uh didn't
live till he was too old though
and we'll get into a while i'm talking
about the soldiers yeah i know some of
them might have lived to their to be old
but we'll get into why that happened
because i'd be like what are you going
to play with that [ __ ] eating
all that damn mercury well well you
spoiled it i'll say it okay
okay
he's running
chinese medicine wasn't what you think
it was
mr 88 said uh isn't chicken [ __ ] the yen
to massive ego's yang yes
i don't want to say he's generally i
don't want to say he's a chicken [ __ ] i
didn't meet him uh
[ __ ] no i'm just saying that that's
well i mean i was just being uh you know
kind of facetious but i meant that
a lot of the um
you know the reason that he built that
was because of fear
well he assumed the war would continue
in the afterlife right he would have to
consider that with the mythos that they
believed in and the world the world view
that they had
we died it's just another dimension we
got to continue over there
so
he's going to continue being the first
emperor over there with his armies and
the war continues and we're going to
take over heaven
you know that's that's what he's
thinking
so zhang at this point
he ascends the throne in 247 bce at this
point he is
less than 13 years old
12 and a half i believe he was
so because he was still a kid
um
he actually had like a regent which is
what they usually did in those
situations when a little kid like
ascended to the throne
so when it when he turned 21 in 238 bce
he uh actually
he actually was like [ __ ] this [ __ ] did
a coup in the palace and took over
like like like a man does i guess
um so basically he had like a bunch of
assassination attempts against him
uh you know as again that happened a lot
in the ancient world
and he decided i don't know if he
decided but he just decided he was gonna
do
i'm just gonna take over the rest of
these like warring states and take them
all [ __ ] over
so by 221
bce
he actually ended up defeating the last
remaining independent chinese state
which was called chi and he defeated it
and
by like unified what was known of china
at the time
so for the first time china was unified
under one ruler
now that same year he was 38 years old
and he proclaimed proclaimed himself the
first emperor
now it was at this point that he
actually like changed his name or like
took over the new title which he thought
of himself you know he didn't he wasn't
bestowed he was just like well because
this was a new position nobody had
really done this before
so he's like well i'm not like a just an
old king of like one little state or
nothing like that like back in the day
no uh back in the warring states period
i'm i run all this [ __ ] and above and
yeah yeah so he decided to come up with
the term huang di
yeah now the word huang comes from three
huang or meaning three august ones
who were the three guys that kind of
ruled at the dawn of history
and then the ones that ruled after them
uh d the five d or five sovereigns
and they ruled immediately afterward so
these people were kind of considered
like the perfect rulers they were very
very powerful they lived like a really
long time
and he wanted to like take something
from that it should be noted too that
the word huang also means great or big
um and the word d also means like
supreme god in heaven or the creator of
the world that's what i was gonna say so
he put those two words celestial rulers
yeah he took he put those two words
together yeah um and then became chin
which was the name of the uh you know
state where he came from
uh and then sure huang or huangdi
uh you know meaning pretty much like
great emperor of the world or the first
emperor of the world whatever there was
a
a lot of inferences though in these
titles and the symbolism that they used
used as that he was a celestial deity
that he was something not only was he in
charge of the world as they knew it he
was in charge of outer [ __ ] space
stars and everything
it's quite you know it was
the highest of the high he was a
you know he ruled all this [ __ ]
kind of like
kind of saying that like you rule heaven
well yeah because well much like a lot
of other ancient cultures at the time
well including like the greco-roman
world and stuff like that they kind of
considered you know like the romans like
the roman empire is the entire world
pretty much yeah and the ancient chinese
thought the same way it's just kind of
like this is the entire world yeah and
if you run it then you run all of it
yeah there was
i would almost say he wasn't
like a a roman emperor though closer to
an egyptian pharaoh
almost a religious figure almost yeah it
was yeah it was a similar very parallel
kind of yeah i think almost a man cod
and hugo said it's funny how the chinese
the maya and the egyptians were all
emperors and all believed in the
afterlife lots of similarities in these
games yeah yeah it's a human constant
that's what i mean it's it's just kind
of like that's why you see these kind of
um parallels across you know vastly
different cultures otherwise
is that like i said humans have
certain parameters that they operate
within it's very wide parameters but
you see the same things like repeating
over and over like especially under uh
similar circumstances we live in a very
special
time frame and to me it looks like this
time is
coming to an end but it'll take a long
time
another hundred years probably
but eventually it will go back to what
humans really are which they're like
this
doesn't mean that technology will go
away technology will still be there i
envision the future being more kind of
like dune
like that
a mixture of the ancient and the
futuristic
because that kind of humans are more
built for that
they seem to like it more they thrive
more not a lot of introspection
more
you know this would be kind of
considered fun
you know
but also
the difficulty level a little bit higher
more challenging
not sitting around just getting fat
being lazy
being pampered and [ __ ]
uh see
frank hubert [ __ ] um
the butlerian jihad you can [ __ ] look
that up on youtube and there'll be a
quick little [ __ ]
thing of what the larian jihad was like
people getting fat lazy and weak because
ai computers and [ __ ] robots doing
everything for them
all right and then eventually enslaving
them and making them and then people
rebelling from that and going back to
their roots that's probably what will
happen
because
six thousand years
of human history
shows you what you are and i think it's
good i think it's good we can do it
better next time
they didn't know as much as we know next
time it'd be even better
[Music]
all right so where was i okay
so even though
i guess in the west uh when
when we say like the type that his title
is like huangdi uh they usually render
that as emperor even though
i don't know it kind of there's a lot
more like cultural context behind that i
guess
um it's like a actually like a lot
bigger words like a god emperor pharaoh
it's almost like saying kind of like
that i just kind of feel like it's more
like that yeah i think that's what
they're talking about so what he decided
to do um because he had seen the kind of
political chaos going on with like the
warring states period
so he decides him and his prime minister
whose name was lee c
um they decided they were going to get
rid of feudalism so they abolished it
so what they ended up doing was the
empire that they now ruled over
they divided it into
36
different areas which they called like
commanderies i guess yeah now what they
did was that they put
each of the 36 like little areas they
had a governor that they would
you know put in charge of that but if
you [ __ ] up they could just like fire
you
they also had um
control zones is what they're talking
about right essentially yeah so then
they had like a civilian guy like to run
[ __ ] and a military guy
but they kind of kept them separate so
you could have like different stuff
going on now the civil guy had more
power than the military guy but they
also had another guy
who was kind of like an inspector who
was like a
like an arbiter kind of like
he would arbitrate like if there was
like a disagreement kind of like a
supreme court member yeah and the
civilian guy they would move him around
every few years because they didn't want
anybody getting too much power in any
one area and like like i said like
usurping his power talking about checks
and balances
yeah essentially that's what they were
doing that's what they were doing so not
a bad system
yeah i mean he did some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
but he's crazy yeah he was he definitely
was crazy and did some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
but some of the stuff that he came up
with actually even after the confusions
took over later they kept some of that
stuff because the way it was organized
was working out okay you got to remember
this is the bc period yes this is this
is thousands of years this is uh some
futuristic [ __ ]
okay
and you didn't see anything like this
until the [ __ ] roman republic
all right which is uh
that's around this time but that didn't
a little bit later actually that didn't
last long
so you know no the chinese on top of
their game yeah
yeah yeah so they had like yeah like you
said it's almost kind of like a system
of checks and balance you had a civilian
guy you had a military guy and you then
you had an inspector who
would report on if either of the other
two were [ __ ] up and would also like
arbitrate like disputes between them
yeah and like try to sort it out and
then you had like the civilian guy who
got moved around to different places
because he didn't want any little
coalitions forming that would like like
i said like get in the way of his power
so he kept everybody kind of like
anybody questioning what they would call
federal authority
yeah essentially that's kind of what he
was doing they're talking about states
and the federal authorities what they're
talking about yeah and it's yeah it's
not that different
for these for for people who are like in
europe or outside the united states
america is a copy of rome
with some greco-roman influences america
is almost kind of like what the system
that they're talking here are
our system of states
that's what they're talking about yeah
it's not that very very much state and
state governor state supreme courts
state police and then state armies state
militias or yeah or uh national guard
same thing okay
and then the same thing but okay another
thing that he did too was that
all of the um other warring states that
he had taken over
um all the members of the royal
families like the royal houses of those
taken over states
he made them all move
to the capital of chin where he was
so he could like keep an eye on him
right so they again so they wouldn't
like [ __ ] [ __ ] him over and stab him
in the back is he using them for
anything or they're just staying there
uh they're basically just staying there
and he would keep him under surveillance
in case they
got any ideas he's not using them as a
house
not that i knew of not that i know of he
just wanted to keep an eye on him so
like and make sure they weren't up to
any schneider so it's not as advanced as
a republic but look they may have been
but i you know like i said i just you
know that's that's kind of what they
said he just made them all move there
now
a few things that he did that are pretty
notable and why he gets brought up a lot
in history not just because the
terracotta warriors but because of some
other [ __ ] that he did
he was behind a massive uh extension of
the network of like uh canals and roads
which connected all the provinces to one
another
um so he essentially developed a highway
system uh which you know had been very
piecemeal and very kind of sporadic
before but he did kind of like a very
unifying because he wanted to
make sure that um
you know that all the different former
states like could still trade with one
another and you know military armies
could move around more freely so he
developed a very uh complicated like
road system which had not been done
prior
um he also
economically unified china by
standardizing chinese measurement
like weights and measures which like i
said had been because i kind of feel
like that's in the ancient world
uh and [ __ ] even in europe even up until
the medieval times i think um it was
just kind of like all over the place you
know what i mean if you said oh it's a
this measurement or whatever it wasn't
standardized like from place to place
so he standardized all of that all the
weights and measures he standardized the
currency
um
and things like which you probably don't
even think about but you know like when
you build a cart
you standardize like the width of the
axles so that they would all like go on
on the roads right you know what i mean
so he did all that kind of stuff uh he
civic standardization right that's
essentially what he did like he yeah he
codified and like you know unified the
legal system all that he also unified
like the chinese script because like i
said much like up in europe up until the
middle ages uh everybody just kind of
was like whatever as long as you kind of
like spelling wasn't standardized and
[ __ ] like that so he actually did uh
standardize the script and made it
official throughout all of the uh all of
china
so
you know
before like i think it was mostly like
mutually intelligible but they didn't
really have any kind of like codified
standard
script or language or anything like that
so he kind of took care of that he's
trying to make an empire he's trying to
make it yeah
and larger civilization yeah and you
can't really run
you know an area of that size without
having communication rules and
communication and everybody kind of has
to be on the same page
so
he did do that so it's all very good
practical thinking yeah yeah
um
however
he also uh had pretty much all the
previously existing books burned
uh prior to his rule uh except for some
that were still in the palace archives
and those were mostly stuff about like
agriculture alchemy things like that
but most of the other books
history like before he took over [ __ ]
like that he's like yeah let's get rid
of that so he burned all that stuff yeah
there may be more not great um there may
be more to it than that might have been
that uh the books didn't agree with one
another
so therefore everything was [ __ ]
uh what do you say uh everything was in
conflict in other words you know what i
mean like he had a bunch of history
books but they all conflicted with one
another
and he didn't like what any of that [ __ ]
said
well they're pretty sure that he just
didn't want anybody to have any
information that could be used against
it maybe yeah it could be it could be i
wasn't there i didn't know the guy
so he burned a lot of books and uh
scholars he pretty much executed
so you know well who knows what they
were saying
don't justify it tom well
he might have been speaking out against
him or something like that you know well
maybe they had reason to well he was a
conqueror that's what i mean but
sometimes you gotta conquer some [ __ ] to
build some [ __ ] destroying and creating
is the same act
you have to create this new thing but it
destroys other things so you don't like
it
and uh you're gonna say well you you're
gonna have either shut up or i'm gonna
kill you and wanted to shut up okay you
did
but he was probably pretty ruthless the
chinese were known for being
cold-blooded the rulers were yeah and
even even by those standards like he is
actually kind of uh brought up a lot as
being like particularly ruthless yeah
but i mean it's he wasn't
that unusual in that regard yeah in this
uh in this
era and stuff but yeah because even the
romans were ruthless so yeah
i mean you know
it's the process of editing although i
trust myself around [ __ ] a roman
emperor before a chinese emperor if you
ask me
i could deal with the roman emperor i
could speak to his heart
the chinese
yeah because yeah because you know well
thankfully i'm never going to go back to
that because right no thank you
it's a western mentality anybody from
the western world could understand a
roman
the chinese were cold-blooded and
calculated they were very much a people
with precision they were very smart
but
just read on you'll see you'll see what
i'm talking about there's a lot of stuff
in chinese history
that is a [ __ ] trip
okay
they're people but they're not western
people
they they have their own motives
their own ways of looking at yeah and
like i said i mean it's not that
different when when i read stuff about
asian history um you know it's
it's all understandable yeah it's like
it's not that different than [ __ ] that
went on in the west it's not that
different i don't know japanese stuff
from a lot of their feudal
feudal history their feudal periods like
i could read miyamoto musashi i [ __ ]
understand everything he's talking about
that's what i mean
i know that like some i know that for
it's probably like less so nowadays but
i kind of feel like for a long time
there's this whole ooh east west like
kind of thing but it's like it's not
really that different i can read stuff
about japanese history chinese history
stuff like that and you can understand
like yeah there are some cultural
differences but it's not that different
like you can usually understand
the context behind it
you can usually understand the
difference between
west and east is this though in the west
there was always a thing about
compromise there was a concept of
compromise and collaboration
not so much in the east the east did not
like to compromise daylight
uniformity
singularity you know that everything is
the same or like a regimented
type
lifestyle they were totalitarian
basically
they just always were
it's like this it's not like that
you're different than me you believe
different than me so you have to go
we're not going to meet mid away
they were they were just like that yeah
yeah i see that but like i said there's
commons weren't like that but there's
people like that over here too
so it's like it's not that weird i guess
you could say it's the ruling class and
the overarching
the overarching
cultures were very different the west
always going back to ancient greece and
in ancient greece
just ask me i'm the
most ancient of all
mississippian greeks okay thomas russell
opolis okay for everything degree what
are you even talking about greeks
greece was the [ __ ] cradle of the
western civilization and they were
philosophers they were about let's meet
some [ __ ] halfway yeah there's truth and
there's falsehood but you know but let's
discuss they can discuss some [ __ ] right
yeah exactly we don't gotta kill each
other exactly i mean they did but you
did but let's find some cool [ __ ] and
it'll all be good but the idea was let's
try not to do that yeah it was the ideal
the idea was pluralism we can be
different but we can still [ __ ] do
some cool [ __ ] together
that's not the way that east was
the east was you obey
it's going to be like this
you know what i mean yeah they were i
don't work well on that they were very
authoritarian okay i don't work well in
authority we will all be the same
very much uniformity
okay now and the japanese being the
least of that
although no no i backed off the koreans
when i lived in korea the koreans are
kind of like the latins of the [ __ ]
of the eastern people
um koreans are a little hot more hot
blooded than the japanese but the
koreans and the japanese they're a
little more
free-spirited compared to say especially
these ancient chinese these ancient
chinese boy they were [ __ ] tough but
they didn't play
yeah well i mean even by western
standards and like i said you know even
i don't know
they were very military it's like a very
military-minded people like regimented
very regimented
authoritarian that's what you're talking
about there
right
cause like i said i'm a military man
but
the military existence is for
select few people in the west
not every westerner can do what i do all
right i have a special place in the
culture
in eastern culture it's all regimented
everybody
you know civilian and military is about
the same
see like i said i'm not i'm not a big
fan of that i'm not a big fan of that
yeah you wouldn't like it
no i don't i don't like anything that
has to do with like hierarchies or
authoritarianism right yeah yeah because
i don't like being told what to do i
like to be left to my own devices and
like cause like i'm not hurting anybody
i'm not doing anything [ __ ] up or
anything like that it's just like that's
a very weird [ __ ] alone there's a very
western attitude very western which i
understand it i'm like that too that's
that's a very western attitude tammy
said oh my god we need a t-shirt with
tom looking like an ancient roman with
laurel wreath and toga i already got one
didn't i make it
a birthday card one year it was me on a
roman coin with a face that's right i
did yeah yeah but it was a long time ago
yeah i made i made like a like i
photoshopped like a roman coin with
tom's face on it but he had like the
wreath and everything thomas
yeah
i did that and one year this was a few
years ago she did me what you did wanted
me as a [ __ ] as a communist premier
that's what i was gonna say
i did a birthday card i made him a
birthday card one year because like i
said i'm a graphic designer i made him a
birthday card one year that was him
because i had this great photo of him
like looking all with his chin up and
everything like that and i said man i'm
gonna make like a communist propaganda
poster out of that so i mean like like
he was lenin or some [ __ ] yeah so i made
something that looked like that it was
so epic i think i still have it
somewhere yeah it looks so good i might
have it on youtube or on facebook i
think i still have that file someplace
i gotta use that [ __ ] on the show
we should make a shirt with that on it
because i actually was really proud of
that design but it came out really nice
i thought it came out really nice i'm
sure i still have it i don't i i keep
pretty much everything yeah but you know
what i mean hey i pay for dropbox to
have like unlimited [ __ ] storage so
so i keep everything because you never
know when you're gonna need it
uh so yeah so while he was in
uh he
you know he did all he burned all the
books and executed the scholars like we
were talking about he also continued the
military expansion
uh started like annex and some reasons
to the south and then there was like a
bunch of sort of like nomadic tribes to
the north and he kept like like fighting
them and [ __ ]
um now he eventually kind of like
defeated them sort of
but he didn't want the tribes coming at
his like northern
face any longer
so what he decided to do
was he started building a big ass wall
now i know you're thinking that it's the
great wall of china kinda it's like the
proto-great wall of china
because
prior to this there were other like
defensive walls like each state kind of
had their own little thing where they're
kind of like hey you stay over there
like we'll build up you know good fences
make good neighbors kind of thing
um so what he tried to do
was make a wall that sort of like
you know uh linked all of those previous
walls together so he was like making one
big one
and like i said i read a couple things
that said oh this is was the great wall
of china no it's not it was like the
proto-great wall of china it was the
same idea but it was like in a little
bit different area and honestly he only
built it over like 10 years so it was
kind of like a little bit of a [ __ ]
wall and i don't think any of it still
exists they wanted to see the coin and
the communist pitcher oh he still has it
yeah i had it
oh tom mystically domestically that's
right
okay i'll show you the communist one
there's the comment oh he found it he
found it yeah he found it
yeah i mean it had wording on it too but
yeah i got it
i think i got the word i can't remember
what the word again had a hamburger and
everything like that because i did like
the whole because i love i have it
someplace yeah because i love honestly i
love all that communist propaganda art i
love that look and it was very very big
in the 80s
like all of that kind of but i love like
i love the the aesthetic of that
so i made him a card because i thought
that'd be super funny they're all in
there laughing i took that picture
i took that picture of you
when we went to that house for two for
you to do that video shoot you remember
that they're all laughing and you were
pretending to be and i said i was gonna
take a picture i said pretend to be an
actor yeah and you were like i'm an
actor yeah and i took the picture and
then like later when i was making the
communist fish i'm like oh my god that's
like perfect yeah
and i got like a comment
and i was like
yeah so i was like all right i'm gonna
take that and run with it [ __ ]
me is
mystically it's optimistically that's
right
i don't even remember like why i ended
up making that
but
and why it was the [ __ ] we were
talking about it's like we always like
talk about we're talking about some [ __ ]
yeah and then like later on i'm like oh
i'm gonna make that so yeah so like some
days like i was farting right at work
and like i made that like about [ __ ]
15 minutes
to please i'm gonna start talking and
i'm gonna start calling it's my roman
that's my [ __ ] greek name to
mystically
well like well i think i thought of that
because mystically is rasaopoulos
because i remember like seeing a
comedian a long time ago except when the
review was any ancient greece called
testicles yeah
so i think i was thinking of that so i
was taking it like thomas but also like
testing i was making a video or
something but i made that music video
yeah when we did that that birthday
massacre one i mean they wasn't like it
wasn't actual birthday massacre it was
like the we knew these two guys that
were video directors and they were
entering a contest like the birthday
massacre this was like years ago they
had a contest where fans could submit
videos
and
they wanted to make one and they asked
tom to be in it uh as like the villain
so
we had to go to this house one day it
was him and like our friend ari she was
like the girl in it she was like an
alice in wonderland type situation and
she kind of looked like that and so they
did that but like tom was the villain he
had like a sword i don't know i don't
remember what the i don't remember what
the story was but um
but yeah so we went to this house and we
were there all day where they were
shooting this video
and that's when i took that picture i
took the picture of him outside and i
told him it was like oh you're gonna be
like an actor i said i said pose like an
actor
and so that's what he did that i made
the comic card
i don't know i thought it was funny
anyway um let's see uh tammy said i
would definitely buy those shirts
i don't remember like that probably i
don't remember how big that
uh that coin file is i feel like it's
probably small but i could remake that
like pretty easily
because i still have that picture of him
i mean that i could do that in like 20
minutes
uh so yeah so at this point yeah he he
builds like the proto
great wall of china i mean the actual
great wall of china was built during the
ming dynasty right and at that point
like
china had like twice as many people as
it had like back when
emperor zhang
emperor chin
was doing his thing
and it took like
about a hundred years to build the
actual great wall which is still there
uh whereas his wall was more like a 10
year so it was kind of a little bit
janky i was like i said i don't think
it's uh there's very very there's not
much of it left anymore so it and it was
like not in the same spot either it was
like farther away
so
now later in his life though we talked
about this i thought this was like
really interesting
so um
so chin do you want some chasing that
yeah
yeah kind of like uh cool kind of like
warmed up it's still good though but
it's not cold anymore
um so later on in his life uh chin sure
huang
he was really really afraid of death
like i said so he kind of wanted to be
one of those [ __ ] that wanted
to live
forever so one of the sort of quests
that consumed him
during the last part of his life
was that he was looking for
essentially an elixir of immortality
and he spent uh several of his last
years like uh doing this kind of stuff
and because he was so afraid of death
and because he was so convinced that
there was an immortality elixir out
there somewhere he probably fell for a
lot of like snake oil salesmen and like
bullshitters who were kind of like oh
yeah i've totally got this here buy this
from me for whatever
so yeah he probably fell for that kind
of stuff
he went to this one place called zifu
island jifu island i'm not sure if i'm
pronouncing it right like i said i know
i'm gonna butcher all these names and
i'm sorry about that
but he went there because he thought
that would make him live forever
so one of the things that he did like
later on in his life
so
there's a guy named uh jufu and he was
from this island which was supposedly
some mythical mystical place where like
immortality happened or whatever
so he sends jufu
and a bunch of ships with a whole bunch
of people on them
and they're looking for this mountain
which i think is called penglai penglai
and they were looking for this dude
named
anki shang
who was a thousand-year-old magician
now
chin they're looking for merlin yeah
chin claimed that he had met this
[ __ ] before okay
and
uh and he told him like some mystical
[ __ ] like if you want immortality come
find me here my son blah blah so he
thought so he's gonna go look for him
right
so he didn't go but he sent like this
boat full of like a hundred of like men
and women and this other person like uh
like this uh guy from zifo island to
look for them and those [ __ ]
never came back now nobody knows if they
just like you know died in a shipwreck
or if they got there and there wasn't
[ __ ] all there and they're just like
well [ __ ] we can't go back or we'll get
executed which is probably like the more
likely scenario
um
legend says though that they actually
got to japan and colonized it that's how
the legend goes that that's where the
first colonizers from japan came from
now uh
there's also kind of a thing
where uh you know like all this all the
books he burned and all the scholars
that he um
you know executed
some have speculated that that might
have happened like that the executed
scholars were actually people that he
had summoned there to
get immortality like he was asking them
to do like some supernatural [ __ ] and
they couldn't do it
um
so some people have said that that maybe
that was why he killed them
maybe because he was really scared to
death he was really scared of evil
spirits
and
it's also rumored that underneath his uh
he had a whole bunch of palaces
and that he had a whole bunch of like
tunnels and passageways and [ __ ] like
that like in between all the palaces so
he could go in between so the evil
spirits couldn't get him
so like i said he was scared
the evil spirits he's talking about are
the slain
enemy chinese yeah
yeah that's what he's talking about he
killed a bunch of people he feels guilty
for it he thinks their souls are after
him
like i said
for such a p f for such a people for a
people of such precision all right they
were still very much into the paranormal
in the spirit world which is why the
communist chinese have banned it so much
because i think that's their weakness
their uh because they saw that over and
over again what's he worried about them
for well he is a conscious they didn't
have psychologists
that could come in and talk to him say
yeah you you were this was gold directed
violence you did what you had to do to
unify the country a bunch of people died
yeah unfortunately a lot of people
[ __ ] died you didn't expect them
gotta break a few eggs you gotta break a
few eggs and that's how it goes
sometimes but if you gotta look at
history man all of history's like that
not really on you this is all part of
nature you know what i mean so you
couldn't talk him out of that
see he thought the dead souls were after
him
okay yeah
um
it was understandable and he didn't have
anybody to talk to okay yeah and uh
there was there was probably no man that
he knew of that was like him that had
come before him
so he thought he had broken that he
broke it
i thought he broke it you know i [ __ ] i
broke it
they come to get me
that's what's happened yeah i could put
myself in his shoes
i mean that makes total sense to me like
in the context of the time you would
probably think that yeah and like you
said you know nowadays you just be like
oh the dude had a conscience like maybe
he actually felt bad that he killed all
his people he did i'm sure he did um but
he wouldn't admit it or he didn't
realize nothing he could have done or
something like that and so
it manifested itself as
like a supernatural oh they're coming to
get me after well they believed in that
stuff
you don't have a religion that's uh
uh you don't have a [ __ ]
judeo-christian yahweh based religion
where there's
yeah there's a god in heaven that
controls heaven he created you
your people chose him as a god oh and
you could atone for sin and be forgiven
and found salvation there's none of that
there's just an afterlife
and there's nobody in charge of that
there's no centralized god
so what you're dealing with is
the living world is a jungle
nobody runs the jungle
it's a fight for survival turns out
you're the biggest tiger in the jungle
but you've made a lot of enemies
when you die you go into the heaven and
the afterlife and it's another jungle
and you better bring your army with you
because they're all your enemies are
waiting for you over there
yeah that's what's happened that's
what's happened
because in a judeo-christian type
mindset when you say heaven you're
thinking about yeah that the god the
devils there's heavens and hells
when you go to heaven
god's in charge of heaven you're not at
risk well in the chinese mind you go to
heaven and nobody runs the [ __ ]
it's just another general it's just
another jungle
so you better be ready that's what he's
talking about
think about it i kind of feel like a lot
of ancient cultures had that kind of
belief because well that's kind of why
well yeah but that's why you see stuff
like the ancient egyptians like the
pharaohs were buried with all kind of
like [ __ ] no they're not armies but
everybody kind of believed that more of
the same was going on now no actually
judeo-christian religions are a copy
of the ancient egyptian ones you go you
die
you're you're judged by anubis in your
heart against the weight of a feather
and if you're guilty or not if you're
guilty then you go to either shoal or
the [ __ ] you go into the underworld
which is hell or you go to heaven
but when you go to heaven amun is in
heaven or an osiris there's a hierarchy
there's a god hierarchy that runs heaven
you don't run heaven and heaven isn't
the wild jungle
so no
different
they went
to the little [ __ ] afterlife and into
the city of the dead they had little
comforts with them but that was to help
them in the afterlife that was just like
their living quarters and [ __ ]
and the little bows that they would need
to
hunt animals in the happy hunting ground
they didn't bring any war material there
so there was peace in egyptian heaven
think about it
they didn't bring any war material no
but what i was saying what i was saying
was that the ancients largely you know
at least the powerful ones
you know they assumed that whatever was
going on in your life you would need
some of that [ __ ] like in the afterlife
so a lot of them were buried with it
yeah yeah that's all i was saying okay
well i thought you meant that in the
egyptian heaven was chaos no no no no
egyptian heaven was peace went on a
totally different i don't know i didn't
mean it any of that i've been drinking
yeah
you hear things that i don't say
the chinese version of in the chinese
cosmology
heaven was just another place
it was a a jungle over there too
in the ancient egyptian heaven heaven
was being ruled by all moon or atun
and then maybe his son you know which
would have been you know [ __ ]
uh uh horus
the risen osiris
okay
depending on what because there was
about three or four different versions
of the egyptian religion as it as it
evolved you know but no there was peace
in egyptian heaven it was a lot like the
christian heaven the christian heaven
was based on it
same with the with the with the islamic
heaven it's based on the egyptian
version of it there's a ruler and we of
heaven and when you go there you're
taken care of it's gonna be okay you
might have to hunt
you might need some [ __ ] acrobats to
entertain you some television to watch
you might need some food you know what i
mean some spiritual food but your
enemies can't [ __ ] with you over there
because the governor will get it that's
you know
that's the world you talk about
yeah in my tomb i just want like a whole
bunch of books and like some maybe like
some cookies right yeah
and a coffee pot oh no i'm good
uh so yeah so the emperor died in
september of uh 210 bce
now he was actually uh when he died this
is a hilary story i don't i mean it's
grotesque but i thought it was funny
because that's my sense of humor
so he's on a tour of eastern china and
he's looking for like i said he's real
into this immortality [ __ ]
so he's looking for
uh this place called the islands of the
immortals which obviously doesn't exist
but he thinks that it's around somewhere
so he's looking for it but while he's on
this tour looking for it he dies i
believe he was only 49 or 50 years old
uh reportedly what most people uh think
that he died of they're not entirely
sure because like i said this was a long
time ago but they think what he died of
was mercury poisoning because in the
ancient times because mercury is like so
cool and so pretty and everything like
that
um
he thought that
taking uh mercury pills or drinking a
little bit of mercury that was going to
make him live forever well wasn't just
him a lot of people thought yeah well
yeah like a lot of people thought that
like i said like that was kind of like
common thinking back in the time he was
taking that was the hrt of the time
ironically
that made you live uh much less time and
drove you insane
that too yeah that too yeah so uh yeah
nobody knows for sure if that's what he
died of but i kind of suspect this yeah
he was [ __ ] crazy
they had evidently the ability to take
mercury and make it into a little black
ball that you could chew and eat
and maybe he was eating it look how
pretty it is it's there's no way it
could be bad or poisonous
think about it
it was a metal but it was
liquid if you were to put it into a big
bathtub you could you could get on top
of it and float around and do crazy [ __ ]
on it it was definitely from their point
of view paranormal
well yeah
i mean even nowadays it kind of seems
like pretty weird when you see it in
action you could have it touch other
metals and it would just
disintegrate those metals just to just
absorb them i think it uh there's a
couple i think it can do that to gold
i don't remember what it it some other
or lead
mercury can touch some of those metals
and then it makes that metal vanish
so you're seeing magic before your eyes
so therefore if you eat it you can live
forever makes total sense makes total
sense
pro tip yeah do not drink mercury to
live forever no don't drink mercury it
won't end well the only thing worse
would be to drink uranium okay
don't drink that [ __ ]
yeah please don't
your kidneys have no way of getting that
out of your system and it goes into your
brain and causes your [ __ ] brain to
do some crazy ass [ __ ]
but evidently uh sharon d in his final
years was incoherent and hallucinating
most of the time
and like i said he didn't live until
very long yeah i think he died when he
was 49 yeah yeah which is my age right
now yeah
so
they had not yet i'm not drinking
mercury either they had not yet
discovered testosterone and hair dye you
could have [ __ ] made him feel like he
was living forever and if you could keep
his hair dyed [ __ ] black or you know
he's getting moisturized
yeah and [ __ ] bumpy about with some
tests he'd be great till he's 70. so i
can still bounce on the [ __ ]
look at my abs i'm 73.
i'm going to live forever well no but
you'll have a good quality of life
[Laughter]
tom has to inject testosterone into
every single show i inject the
testosterone
i'm here to support men's health
and we're supporting men's health by
saying please don't drink mercury don't
drink mercury don't drink mercury it
shouldn't have to be inject testosterone
but you don't really know i mean you
know
you don't really know what what stupid
[ __ ] people will do seriously don't
drink marijuana i know it's i know it's
pretty but but don't drink it okay so
now he dies
he dies wait wait now we're into the
[ __ ] okay but wait this is a great
story okay after he died okay so he's
prime remember i mentioned his prime
minister a while back called lisey
now so
because the emperor dies like while
they're on tour yeah
lisey thinks to himself [ __ ] i can't
really tell anybody that he died because
there's gonna be like a big uprising he
wasn't like a super popular guy like
there was a lot of like like a lot of
people were ruled by fear that's what
i'm saying so a lot of people were kind
of like so he's like well [ __ ] we can't
tell anybody
uh about this and it's like and it's
gonna take us two more months
to get back to where we were going
so he's like here's what we're going to
do we're not going to tell anybody even
in the entourage
we're not going to tell anybody that he
died
so much so that the prime minister would
go into the wagon where the emperor's
body was and pretend to be like
consulting with him on some [ __ ] now
they said this only worked because the
emperor was kind of secretive to start
with so like people didn't it wasn't
weird like for people not to see him for
several days well no i that i'm getting
into that just give me a minute all
right and another thing the prime
minister this is pretty genius prime
minister
like he thought of that he's like oh my
god the shit's gonna stink like after a
couple days so he's like okay um what we
need to do is we're gonna have like this
big cart full of fish yeah in front of
and behind the amber yeah yes so that if
anybody if anybody's like what's that
[ __ ] stink oh this is a fish bro yeah
it's not the rotting body no there were
carrick references but
i don't know why i thought that was so
funny but i was just kind of like that
is so grotesque
and yet still hilarious yeah that just
made me laugh so hard i'm like oh my god
i have to put that in there that's so
[ __ ] funny so uh so they made it back
after two months and then of course they
had to report the death he's like he's
been dead the whole time
it was like that kind of situation
now uh so while he was alive uh the
emperor obviously was since he was
terrified of death he didn't like to
talk about death so he didn't have a
will
what ended up happening after he died
was that the prime minister lisey and
the chief eunuch i love that they used
to have a chief eunuch yeah whose name
was uh xiao gao yeah like i said i'm
sure i'm butchering these names so
you go on what because you mentioned the
eunuchs
eunuchs played a big part in chinese
history when i talked about zhang ha the
guy who [ __ ]
ran that naval expedition and did
fantastic things even went to europe
in steamships back in the 1500s he was a
eunuch
there were a lot of eunuchs in china
they were like the if you were if you
know the dune universe they were like
the mentats of the chinese they were
like the laptops you smart [ __ ]
you could buy them you could train them
and educate them up
and they would help you run your country
and you could trust them around your
women because there's no way they could
get a woman pregnant they couldn't do
anything they could just kind of lay on
her and
and hump well evidently well
she's laughing evidently the [ __ ]
eunuchs had
female fans that i see that that that
[ __ ] loved them but what the deal was
is
evidently
their owners didn't care if they had sex
with women or not they just wanted to
make sure that there was no way
they could sire offspring right so yeah
that's that was all that's all it was
that way they could not
your children were always gonna be yours
not his that's that's all it meant
that way whoever ended up on the throne
was your son and not not your right-hand
man's son
but uh a eunuch was usually your
right-hand man
he was the one running the [ __ ] show
kind of like
your laptop
your ai laptop
so a lot of the most powerful people in
china over that in this period of
history lasted a long time centuries
where eunuchs
and it was a it was a proud position
yeah well like i said they had a chief
eunuch yeah and this guy was like way up
in the thing because the prime minister
who is kind of in charge because now the
emperor died yeah so him and the chief
eunuch they get together
and they talk to
the emperor's one of the emperor's sons
uh who hi and they said hey you need to
like forge a will
for your dad
uh so they did
now another one of the emperor's sons
fusu uh they made him commit suicide you
know not cool
uh
took away like they there was another
guy that was a big supporter of fusu the
sun who had like a whole bunch of troops
and they took away his command
and then they killed his entire family
so you know nice
uh so who hired the son he ended up
becoming the second emperor
and he uh became known later as uh chin
air she or sure
so
we'll just call him uh
fusu though because that's easier to
pronounce
now
you mentioned earlier that this uh
particular reign of this emperor the
first emperor of china uh didn't last
too long after his death i think it
believe i think it lasted like four
years and then it started collapsing and
i think it was because well his son took
over
um because like i said they forged the
will because there wasn't one now the
thing about fusu the sun was that he was
kind of i don't i don't think it was a
[ __ ] up it was just he wasn't like um he
didn't have the same uh thing that his
dad had
so when he comes in and i think like a
lot of resentments against his dad
kind of boiled over and he didn't really
have the intestinal fortitude to
fight it
so a bunch of revolts started happening
so he's in like a whole bunch of civil
unrest is going on uh everything that
the first emperor had done like kind of
started falling apart
uh at least for a short period
um the imperial palace got burned like a
lot of state art archives are burned um
and historians nowadays are like
freaking out about that because they're
like jesus christ it's like you know
it's bad enough that
you know the emperor like burned all the
[ __ ] books but then like the [ __ ]
afterward like a bunch more [ __ ] was
burned so there's hardly anything left
from that time period
um the palace archives survived but not
much else
so basically uh within about four years
of the emperor dying uh his son also
died and that dynasty pretty much came
to an end uh so that was very very
short-lived like all the [ __ ] that he
did like pretty much fell apart like uh
right after he died because there were
so many revolts and stuff like that
um so basically after he after the sun
died uh they come out like back into
essentially what
kind of what was going on before you had
like all these kind of like powerful
families and they're like all warring
against one another strongest ones come
into power you know
it's just kind of like the next dynasty
of emperors like comes along yeah and
the next uh chinese dynasty which was
the han dynasty uh actually got rid of
legalism which was the philosophy that
uh the first emperor was like uh worked
on in favor of confucianism and they
kept some of his [ __ ] but
moderated with some other stuff and um
you know that's kind of like just the
way it kind of went
after there
now let's talk about his mausoleum yeah
now we're getting to the show i mean
well that was a vision now i called the
show yeah like that you're in the
background so you know okay yeah the guy
that so you understand the significance
of all yeah the context of like why it
was built and [ __ ] like that
so he gets buried in his mausoleum now
his mausoleum was actually started to be
constructed like when he first
kind of like he didn't come to power
because he was only 13 but they started
building it then
so it took like 38 years and they
actually didn't finish it i think they
didn't finish it until like a few years
after he was dead so it took like a
really really long time we're talking
about like from when he was 13 to i
think four years after he died
so i think it took like 38 40 years
something like that
like to build because it's a massive
massive complex
of which the terracotta warriors are
just like kind of a small uh part of it
so uh
yeah the thing about it is that i think
obviously like scholars kind of knew
about it because it had been written
about but nobody but nobody could see it
because it was buried
and they didn't really find it like it
was pretty much buried underground for
more than 2 000 years
what ended up happening was in march of
1974
there was a bunch of farmers like a
little group of farmers like i think it
was like a dad and his sons or something
like that and they were digging a well
um a little bit like about a mile like
east of the tomb mound because there's a
mound there it's like an earth mound it
looks kind of looks like a pyramid but
like with a flat top kind of
so
they start digging a well there and
there because there's like a whole bunch
of underground springs and stuff
now
they kind of suspected like
archaeologists have like this kind of
suspected there might be something there
because they thought yeah it's probably
like a tomb complex and over the
centuries like little pieces of like
like terra cotta pieces like roof tiles
little pieces of stuff like kept turning
up so like oh maybe there's something
interesting in there but nobody had
really done any excavation spot take
them out people take them out yeah
because i can't do it from here yeah
um but yeah so people suspected there
might be something there but nobody
really thought that much about it um
but
what ended up happening was that these
farmers kind of busted through and they
found
like a couple of
what looked like like statues of people
that were made of terracotta and they're
like oh these are interesting
so they bring them to some local
officials and then
you know archaeologists in the area kind
of got really interested so like we're
gonna go like [ __ ] check this out
so as i said the terracotta army like
after they started digging and they're
like holy [ __ ] this place is [ __ ]
massive
um but it's part of like a much bigger
it's essentially like a necropolis is
what it is uh the inner city part is
about a mile and a half and then like
the outer one is almost like four miles
so it's like a massive massive area
now the main tomb which
supposedly contains the emperor and
among many other things and like i said
there's a lot of stories about what
might be in there
they haven't really opened it like i
said they've excavated about one percent
of it but at this point they're kind of
like being really kind of like cautious
about getting in there because they
don't know because of the mercury and
all this other stuff they don't really
know what they're going to find in there
and they don't really want to [ __ ] it up
so
they're just kind of going about it
really slowly
they don't know if it is still intact if
it's been looted they don't really know
at this point
um
it's the legend says that it was sealed
with molten copper i don't know if
that's true or not
so the necropolis complex
um
pretty much what they think it looks
like is that it was like
a microcosm of his
empire and his palace
like the two mound would be at the
center and then there'd be like walls
like inner outer walls
uh you know outside of the tomb mound
and then like there'd be like a bunch of
pits which is what they have found like
the pits
have uh you know both inside and out the
walls those are the ones that have
the terra cotta soldiers in them
now in the inside the inner wall was a
pit that had like all those bronze
chariots and like the horses in there
and then in the inner wall they found
like these terracotta figures of like
bureaucrats and courtiers and stuff like
that because like i said they're not all
soldiers most of them were most of them
are infantry soldiers but there are like
other
uh figures there's musicians there's
like guys playing like [ __ ] violins
or whatever there's all of like acrobats
there's all kinds of stuff in there
now
so they oh and strong men they have like
strong men too which i thought was
really funny
now um
being ex-infantry myself i'll tell you
that what was portrayed out of the
terracotta army is an entire army it's
the army yeah and the entertainment
segment
and the horses and everything okay
it's everything you would want to have
with you
if you were
in this time period in the army so yeah
well thought out well done yeah i mean
the amount of work that went into this i
know it took a really long time like i
said it wasn't just like oh i'm gonna
die soon like build this [ __ ] they
started building it when he was like a
13 year old kid yeah
he didn't finish it until after it would
be the equivalent of its army with the
television and all of its [ __ ]
entertainment and his food and its
[ __ ] horses and
uh transportation like
jeeps for your officers that's that's
it's that that's that's what it is
there's animals in there so there's
animals yeah there's cranes there's uh
ducks swans yeah all kind of [ __ ] well
they ate those
but i mean they're all yeah they made
like bronze figures of them they're like
next to the musicians it's like like i
said it's like an entertainment it's
just everything everything you would
want
yeah because
you don't want your soldiers to
experience hardship
and deprivation in the afterlife so
anything that they would want on the
battlefield for rnr rest and relaxation
they got it that's what that's what this
is
it's just an ancient way of looking at
it
yeah yeah
and also um they found a mass burial
ground for a lot of the laborers who
worked on the complex yeah and who died
during because a lot of people died
building yes like i said it took a long
time to make it and i'm sure it was very
labor-intensive
and a lot of people were
kind of conscripted to work on it you
kind of had to work on it or you know
that was kind of all there was to do so
yeah a lot of people did die so there's
like big mass graves for all the people
that died working on it well they worked
on it for a long time people are going
to die that's what i'm saying yeah so
but yeah like i said this is over like a
38 40 year period period that they
worked on this because it's probably a
pr probably just like the pyramids a
privilege to work on it and a privilege
to be buried on the site because that
meant your soul also would be there in
heaven with all these people yeah so
yeah
there used to be there used to be
they used to say that you know that the
pyramids were built by slaves and this
no they were built by artisans that
wanted to do this and professionals that
they wanted to do this and this was
their ticket into heaven
and to be set up in heaven that's why
you worked on these projects
it'd be the same with the chinese that's
when you look at that craftsmanship
that's not slaves that's people that
wanted to do that [ __ ]
this is their ticket into heaven
to do this
so they believe in what they're doing
you may not believe in it but they
believe in it
you know well yeah they might have like
largely or i know they do
yeah
but uh yeah so like i said they haven't
really gone too much into the tomb
itself but they have done some you know
uh non-invasive like explorations of the
site they found like the underground
palace uh what they think is the
underground palace like in the middle of
the mound they've done like an
archaeological survey of it and like a
magnetic uh kind of study of it
and they think what they see underneath
the mound i don't think they've gone in
there physically but what they see
underneath the mound it's a 13 foot high
perimeter wall made a brick
and that's supposed to be like because
like i said it was like a microcosm of
his
palace and his empire that they built
like kind of in miniature
uh in this sort of necropolis so there's
a 13 foot high wall and that's you know
bricks and that's supposed to be like
the
kind of the wall of the underground
palace and then there's an there's
another like kind of wall that's made of
like packed earth that's about 115 feet
high
and then you have kind of like these
sloping passageways going up to
uh you know the walls
and then you have uh all these passages
that go to the pits and that's what like
the pits are where kind of like the
um the chariots and the horses and like
the soldiers and stuff like that so the
tomb chamber where they assume that the
body is they don't really know
but the tomb chamber is about 260 feet
long
uh and 16 feet wide and about 50 feet
high
so they can determine that without
digging into it
now
why people are so fascinated with the
tomb
is that there was a guy a historian
named uh sema
i guess that's how you would pronounce
that i'm not entirely sure i can't see
it um it's how you spell it
s-i-m-a-q-u-q-i-a-n
yeah i wouldn't know yeah yeah
like that's like like you know that's a
hard one no i do understand a lot of
their products but yeah but the way they
[ __ ] write that [ __ ] out in our
characters sometimes it's gonna be very
very [ __ ] confusing well yeah
now he wrote about
the tomb complex
like not even 100 years after the
emperor actually died
and he said all kind of cool [ __ ] was in
there
he said and i think he brought this up
before there's like there's a whole map
of like the heavens in there yeah with
all the stars like with pearls like for
each of the stars i don't know okay but
he wrote about it
it hadn't been 100 years since he died
so maybe he did see it i don't know okay
because you know it was possible or or
there were people that built it that
told him what was in there maybe yeah i
don't know if he saw it like first hand
but
yeah he said there was like these big
like celestial maps and the stars all
were like pearls okay and he said on the
floor of the tomb and this is what you
were talking about before there's a big
map of china
and the rivers were all
mercury so like all the like the yangtze
and the yellow river and all that it was
all like with like mercury like they
made it like a big map but like a 3d map
yeah and all the water was mercury yeah
and evidently the source that i heard
said that it was designed that the
mercury flowed
like water
yeah so there must have been a way that
it was pumping
which uh man how the hell did they do
that
yeah and evidently it was
designed to last forever
so you're talking about almost something
kind of like a perpetual motion machine
that's right now you have water clocks
that can do that maybe they made
something kind of like
a mercury clock yeah they had a pendulum
that swung that pumped water and
or
a pendulum that swung and pumped
mercury you know somehow through this
system
and then another thing that was
mentioned from the source that i
remember hearing this is decades ago
that it was lit
by
gas lamps
i guess
depends on the description
but gas lamps that burn forever
that's a tall order what are they
talking about
are they talking about natural gas
natural gas could do that for [ __ ]
tens of thousands of years yeah that's
hundreds of thousands of years
so it's not as crazy as it
sounds but what happens to the soot
from the natural gas over [ __ ] 2000
years is is it entirely blackened in
there now
there couldn't be any ventilation and
then what happens to the oxygen
without oxygen flames can't burn
did the chinese know this this is why i
want to [ __ ] them [ __ ] to go in
there and get in there well like i said
they see what the conversion is like i
said but they don't want to [ __ ] it up
the chinese probably for those very
reasons they're like we really don't
want to like just poke a hole in the
side of the mound and look like air gets
in there and it destroys everything was
in there
before you even get to see and it's kind
of plausible that the chinese knew that
eight that without air nothing that a
flame cannot burn
they would have [ __ ]
tried that yeah i mean that seems like a
pretty self-evident right
uh thing that they would have figured
out a lot so
is there a way to somehow get oxygen in
there
to let the the lighting work
what are they talking about you know i i
you know i i just want i'm just really
i'm dying for them to go in there and
see what it looks like in there i mean i
love the idea like i know mercury's
poisonous and everything but i do love
the idea of like the mercury rivers but
i think i'm more enchanted with the idea
of like the celestial map with the
pearls yeah that sounds fantastic yeah
i hope that's true
and evidently sherwan dee's
concubines
were buried alive in there with him
insane yeah yeah i heard i heard that as
well david italy had cells that they
well now they know they buried some
horse like some real horses in there but
um because they did find that but i
don't know if they've gone in here but
did they kill the horses before they
buried them see i don't know yeah
the way i heard it is that they put a
bunch of people in there alive in cells
and then sealed the tomb up that sounds
like some [ __ ] well the egyptians did
that too
did they i didn't know they did that
well yeah
they had like hey let's put your slaves
in there it's like hey
travel with him to the afterlife bye i
didn't know that i know the vikings did
that kind of [ __ ] i didn't know the
egyptians did that they did yeah
okay so like i said this is not crazy
so
yeah so
so some maybe some of that [ __ ] it's in
there because it should be said that
[Music]
when um
the historian when he said about the
mercury rivers and everyone was like wow
that sounds fantastic we're not sure if
that's true or not but when they've done
like uh samples of the soil and
everything like that they're like holy
crap there's like a [ __ ] ton of like
mercury in there so like maybe he was on
to something like maybe he's not yeah
crazy because they have done like
chemical breakdowns of that i remember
seeing an analysis this is a long time
ago back in the 90s of where on top of
that burial mound they did a bunch of
samples all over it like in a grid
pattern
and the high mercury content
and the low mercury content formed an
image that looked like a [ __ ] map of
the china that
that he ruled yeah it's maybe i don't
know if i'd go that far but they said
they did find like a very like a very
very high concentration of mercury like
yeah so they think that probably because
mercury does kind of give off some gases
yeah and eventually might have went up
through the ceiling and they did the
test and they were like yeah there might
be something underneath there
kind of shaped like the map of china
made out of mercury
i
yeah they just need to go down in there
i mean they kind of think that that's
probably plausible they weren't sure
before but once they did all the
sampling and they're like yeah there's a
[ __ ] ton of mercury like yeah soil there
so maybe he was like he was
basically
based on swords and carriages and things
made out of metal bronze and
you know they made
these guys were good man real good
you look at the [ __ ] that they made it
looks like it was made today
by a computer and a robot
they could make something out of metal
it was [ __ ] just precision beautiful
and it didn't look like they it was
difficult for them to make it it was
like very artistic
smooth flowing lines straight lines when
it had to be straight
the proportions were just perfect
two thousand years ago
yes and it looked like something made in
the twentieth like i said they weren't
dumb yeah it looked like something made
the 20th or 21st century you know
so
it doesn't shock me to think that they
could do something like make a [ __ ]
pendulum running on mercury
as a perpetual motion machine to keep
mercury flowing across the map of china
and weird [ __ ] like that you know and
traps
you know
[ __ ] indiana jones style [ __ ]
traps that if you try to break in
through this side the [ __ ] wall
collapses on you or
arrows shoot out at you you know
wouldn't surprise me
i mean actual lighting gas lighting i
don't think they found anything like
that but they did find because the
historian said
that when they were building the complex
that they had reached uh the ground
water level now they know at that point
at that in that area um the water table
is about 100 feet 98 feet something like
that
so but the thing about it is they think
the complex has a really really good
they found in 2000 they found a dam in
there and like a really really good
drainage system because they're like
there's no evidence that there was any
flooding in there
but it does look like it was deep enough
to get down to the water table but they
essentially like found some way of like
getting the flood waters out of there so
they have some kind of like drainage has
a way to drain water yes okay they have
found that all right
so
so they were thinking they were thinking
about everything yeah
yeah
they've also excavated um
the outside like of the palace that's in
the tomb
there's a whole bunch of other houses
like little houses around the palace
like 18 of them and a big main building
that overlooks those houses and uh so
archaeologists have been kind of slowly
going to like excavating those so they
have found like a bunch of roads a bunch
of like gates and walls and [ __ ] like
that some brick work so they have been
like working on it they are kind of like
slowly going into the complex but what
they found so far was this i was reading
there like a bunch of like walls gates
roads okay that kind of stuff like of
the outer complex because like i said
the whole
tomb complex is supposed to look like
his like a smaller version of his palace
and the surrounding stuff that he ran
any timeline on when that when they'll
get in i don't know they started um
excavating the outer stuff in 2010 okay
and you know like i said it's slow going
but they found a bunch of stuff but you
know they're just slowly working their
way inwards i guess okay
um so we haven't like really talked
about the terra cotta soldiers yes now
interestingly uh the historian there uh
chien
he never mentioned the terracotta
soldiers which is crazy like i said it
was found accidentally
and
it's just kind of like
so as i mentioned earlier they made it
with like they had all these molds
that they made at a clay because they're
terracotta which is just like hardened
clay essentially
and what they would do is they had
they had ten different uh molds of the
heads
they've identified 10
distinct facial shapes among all the
thousands of warriors that they've so
far unearthed and they said what they
probably did was they cast each head
using one of these 10 molds and then
they would individualize
each soldier by adding like mustaches or
eyebrows or whatever the [ __ ]
like just with clay so that's how they
would do it but the bodies and stuff
like that they said were probably made
like an assembly line they said the like
the way they made the legs are hollow
like the way they made the legs and
stuff like that was kind of the similar
way that they would make like terracotta
pipes back then yeah so it wasn't like
all that weird and then they would like
assemble them and they weren't all the
same size though they're not all uniform
like not only are their faces different
because they're all i mean they're
modular
you know so you could just like build
them they built them in pieces and then
kind of like and fired each piece
separately and then assembled them like
on site they didn't like make each one
and then fire it yeah it makes perfect
sense to me yeah yeah yeah what they're
doing is they're mass producing parts to
make a perfect
perfect idealized representation of an
individual soldier
that's what i think they're doing
they're not random
you did some [ __ ] in the
you probably had to earn a position into
being chosen
to be in modeled
as one of these
terracotta warriors
and you've agreed that into in the
afterlife to serve sharawandi
that's what i think is happening
so yeah they give you kind of an
idealized body maybe a little bit better
than the one that you had in terms of
proportion but about the same height to
represent you
and they used a system a modular system
to reproduce your face
and you've agreed to inhabit that thing
in the afterlife
kind of like a golem
yeah you gotta like stay like on post on
post in that [ __ ]
and it's your body but it's like a
better version of the one that you had
in the spirit world
to help [ __ ] conquer some [ __ ] in
heaven
for sure wandee because you never know
when you might need that [ __ ] and it's
probably only the best
of the uh imperial guard or
you know or or the well the imperial
guard would always be the best so it's
the imperial guardsmen
all
are being selected to serve sherwood in
the afterlife
because none of this [ __ ] is by accident
the chinese just don't do some random
[ __ ] this is a well thought out plan
so each one of those statues if you ask
me as a military man
ex-military man represents a military
man
who's given his soul to sherwandee
that's what it is
and i think they made them like
generally taller because they generally
i mean they're life-sized obviously uh
the humans are life-sized the horses are
life-size uh and realistic
i think like the shortest of the figures
is like five nine yeah and the tallest
one is six foot seven that's big for
china and normally like the higher you
are in rank like the taller they meet
you yeah so you know what i mean because
you're talking about two thousand seven
that's very tall 2 000 years ago in
china those those are giants
yeah yeah those are elite soldiers i
mean 5 foot 9 isn't all that that's
probably a little above average nowadays
but in china but
yeah that would have been like that
those are chinese
and six foot seven would have been like
supernatural actually even now if you
saw somebody that's that's financial
yeah because [ __ ] i used to date a guy
that was six five and he was like super
super tall the
the chances of these being random images
is if you ask me zero
these represent dudes that existed
yeah
and they've thrown their lot in with
sherwin d in the afterlife
they were the best that china had
in that era
that's his pro ball team
that's what we're talking about the
dream team it's the dream team yeah but
so far they have found
more than 8 000 soldiers
130 chariots
uh with 520 horses on the chariots and
then they've also found 150 other like
cavalry horses
and as i mentioned earlier there's other
it's not just all it's mostly infantry
but there are like some other uh you
know like acrobats and strongmen and
musicians and [ __ ] like that the
infantry were the main weapons in this
era
you know what i'm talking about that's
what you attacked with infantry yeah
they didn't have artillery
they didn't have [ __ ] armor
you know no tanks it was infantry
so
the imagery was the [ __ ] best weapon
well and like they had artillery but
it'd be like triple sha or something
kind of like [ __ ] uh catapult which
is a big crossbow but i'm not sure the
chinese had that at that period and that
wouldn't have been the main killer the
main killer of an infantry with pole
arms big long [ __ ]
big long [ __ ] um rod
with an axe at the end
maybe a spear point at the tip
that's usually the kind of things that
the chinese used in infantry combat not
even swords
what's called a pole arm
and they fought from phalanx
you know which is side by side real real
[ __ ] close in armor
and they had good armor
looked like samurai armor kind of
but it was a bunch of [ __ ] paper
um
paper armor basically it was i want to
call it paper more like cardboard i get
uh no way to describe it
it was layered laminate and then
lacquered tied to vests
and it it was only designed to absorb
arrows
real good at that real good at that they
they were good they knew exactly what
they were doing their equipment was
perfect for the time they were a good
army
well the interesting thing too about the
the soldiers is that it wasn't just even
though they were built in a modular
fashion like on an assembly line
and even though the faces were
individual like a lot of the armor was
individual too they said even among like
the armor like some of them have like
short pants on some of them have shin
pads some of them don't some have like
different so they made every single one
look completely distinct which is like
pretty pretty awesome well they're
making it to preferences right you know
to for the guy they represent an
individual soldier i'm telling you yeah
i mean they probably did they probably
did
um and then you have some like in
different positions most of them were
standing there but some of them are
kneeling they have like some that are
like groomsmen for the horses kneeling
next to horses and stuff like that yeah
those are your maintenance guys those
are the guys who are motor pool taking
care of the vehicles that's what it is
the best [ __ ] mechanic
that's the best dude that handles a
horse that's what that's what yeah and
as i mentioned earlier i think a lot of
people are just used to
uh seeing the soldiers like in their
sort of like natural terracotta state
but
back then uh they would have been
painted yeah like really really brightly
colored because they wanted them to look
as realistic as possible
so they had like pink pigments they had
like so they painted their faces to look
like human flesh
uh you know they painted their hair that
looked like natural human hair i mean
they had all kinds of like they ground
up like precious stone and bone and uh
charcoal and [ __ ] [ __ ] like that you
tree sap to make like different colors
and i've seen like some um
you know they've done like some digital
recreations of what they think that the
that they probably looked like when they
were
uh you know first done and they look
fantastic yeah they actually look like
real like real people yeah yeah and
they're dapper
yeah very dapper looking dudes
yeah
it's it's the best china hat to offer i
mean it's really a beautiful and i kind
of feel like until these were found
because like i said these were
buried
uh
you know
for thousands of years until somebody
came across them in the 70s and then
when they found it i think that everyone
was kind of astounded because i don't
think that anybody thought
that
that standard of art was
all that prevalent in that part of the
world at that time period which like i
said goes to say you can't you can't
like
underestimate you can't underestimate
like ancient people especially ancient
people that had like pretty much
unlimited
funds and unlimited
manpower
because
uh obviously this took like thousands
and thousands of people and several
decades to accomplish
uh you know it wasn't just one guy i
mean that would really be amazing but
yeah and so i i think that this was a
standard that people didn't really
expect uh from this era so it was like a
really big deal and like i said if you
still see them nowadays it's still
amazing i mean like if somebody made
that [ __ ] now you'd be [ __ ] impressed
so the fact that somebody did that like
thousands of years ago is just like
[ __ ] crazy i would have actually
really liked to see them
with all the original pigment on them
that would have been really really cool
i mean you know i've seen like digital
recreations which
you know but that just kind of makes me
wish that i could just kind of go back
in time for a second and just like
just like see them for real like before
they all got buried because i don't
think i mean they weren't
it's not kind of like um you know some
of the funerary art from other cultures
where it was kind of like meant to be
seen because like hey this person is
dead look how impressive they were in
life so we built like this big
ostentatious thing
i mean he built these warriors because
he legitimately
thought well i need protection in the
afterlife so they were just buried i
mean they weren't
they weren't put there for people to
come gawk at
he legitimately thought
you know i'm gonna need these like to
defend myself so i don't think he didn't
care if anybody saw them so they just
built them and then they just buried him
in this [ __ ] tomb and like they were
you know nobody even everybody forgot
they were there it was like that's
[ __ ] crazy to me it's crazy
um but yeah
now interestingly a lot of the figures
actually used to hold
real
weapons
um so and when they were all painted up
because like i said they were painted to
look as realistic as possible with very
you know flesh tones and like really
colorful uh you know armor and stuff
like that
um so they put real
weapons in their hands
now unfortunately
most of these weapons were
looted uh not too long after
after the tomb was finished just like in
egypt everybody's like oh we heard that
a tomb was finished all right we're
gonna go in there and get that [ __ ] so
yeah the same thing happened in china so
a lot of the weapons were looted but uh
despite that
they did find
they have uh located over 40 000
bronze items
of weaponry so they have actually
recovered that at this stage so even
though a lot of it was looted that just
goes show how much the [ __ ] was in there
because
most of it was looted but they still
found 40 000
bronze weapons
daggers
spears swords lances battle axes all
kind of [ __ ] crossbows all kind of stuff
i saw a [ __ ] i saw a show where a modern
sword expert
was given one of
the bronze swords from sherwin dee's
tomb
or tomb complex
he knew everything about swords and it
was they showed it it was it was first
of all it was [ __ ] beautiful
and it was razor sharp
after 2 000 years
yeah it was razor sharp now bronze
doesn't hold an edge
forever
you know what i mean like
you start banging on people over time it
starts to dent and deform they can fix
cutting off heads you can't be doing
that right yeah they could fix it back
in the days and they would maintain it
so they knew what they were doing with
bronze weapons they weren't as good as
steel weapons but
the romans [ __ ] worked with it for a
long time during that same period bronze
can can be very effective
and it can be very sharp
but he picked it up and he's handling
he's just oh yeah yeah this is it the
balance is good
good thrusting good slashing
good shopping parry you can do all that
with it it was they do exactly what they
were doing
these were military experts of [ __ ]
the highest order
for their era
you know
so you're talking about military
superpower to stuff you guys were not
amateurs they were [ __ ] great real
good
i should add too that they have done uh
studies under electron microscopes of
these
and there is evidence
that
uh a lathe was used for polishing which
may be
that first yeah historical instance that
they know of damn of the industrial use
of elite damn so that's just crazy like
all yeah all the stuff they saw like in
the thing that looks like uh an
industrial label yeah remember i said
earlier on and this is like it looks
like sounds
that's thousands i said that earlier in
the show people i didn't know that we
didn't [ __ ] cool yeah they think that
they looked at some of those that looks
like they came off a lathe
it it did so they had lathes which you
guys don't understand that lays in 210
bc 210 bc the ladies did not exist in
the western world
really until the 1800s
you know late 1800s tammy said it was
aliens
it's not aliens
people are smarter than you give them
credit for that so see i never that's
why like i said i don't like that
ancient alien [ __ ] because it's like man
people back then were not stupid they
figured [ __ ] out yeah
just because we forgot about it or we
didn't know and that was a long time ago
that doesn't mean that they didn't
figure that [ __ ] out right
their motives were different because
they had different
religious motives behind them and
different religious beliefs
but uh you know i got kanavasalan in
here we got a lot of people from central
and south america
i grew up partially in brazil
when you look at the aztecs look at my
hair sticking up over here you don't
understand the average person really
didn't know what they were looking at in
the 18 in the 1900s especially with the
aztec
language with their glyphs you're
looking at emoticons in the emojis yeah
it's what you're looking at and the and
a lot of the a lot of mesoamerican art
and aztec art and mayan are
nowadays you look at it and he goes well
that's kawaii
what the japanese were talking about
it's it's not supposed to be realism
it's a style
okay
you're talking about little [ __ ]
kawaii figures
and and it's you know i mean it's
stylism
and emojis
and just because it doesn't have like a
greco-roman style alphabet does not mean
that it's not an advanced no they were
very advanced
we're [ __ ] in the 21st century on
[ __ ] these little [ __ ] tablets and
computers and we're just now getting
into emoticons the mexicans had the
mayans had that [ __ ] [ __ ] thousands
of years ago
a language based on emojis
and it's an advanced language
like you got a little face in it the
face is slightly different in this one
and
not quite as holding the corn in the
right
angle and three things of corn and it's
because
it's expressing emotion
you know so the emoji is expressing
emotion emotion which that's advanced
that's very interesting i kind of think
a lot of the problems i think that the
the reason that people nowadays
understand like that ancient people
were kind of like the same as us so it's
like they kind of like get it yeah and i
think that the problem was i think was
this kind of like imperialist
attitude that
because there was everybody in britain
and the early united states where
they're kind of like oh these savage
cultures and yeah they don't have a true
alphabet they don't like know any better
and it was just kind of like so so it
was very like patriarchal like
condescending yeah a paternalistic i
guess yeah and so
to them it's like oh well they can't
possibly be as smart as siblings as we
are so obviously there must be something
else going on so i think they couldn't
really understand or they couldn't
really relate
to
i mean nowadays like i said you look at
like you know maya stuff and you're just
like oh well that looks like emojis i
mean yeah that's essentially what it is
right that's what it is the the vatican
is [ __ ] telling all the okay the
vatican is telling all these dominican
friars to burn all this
mexican all these mexican and mayan
writings and the [ __ ] mexican
or see and then the dominican friars are
[ __ ] sending
messages back
to spain going no you don't understand
these are [ __ ] vast
vast libraries of [ __ ] writing yeah
it's like it's a [ __ ] dude yeah
they're communicating yeah and you're
talking about you're talking about uh
something on par with like the ancient
greece and the romans these guys
this is you know they have a lot of
knowledge to burn it burn it
i mean just the just the audacity of
making that like oh well they obviously
don't know what we know so we need to
get rid of that yeah that sense well
they wanted to stop what they thought
was devil worship which yeah it was only
devil worship in the way and they're in
their views they were paying off devils
they weren't worshiping them they were
trying to bribe evil death well yeah
that's kind of like
that that's a totally legitimate like
you're just kind of like well we know
that there's like bad [ __ ] or like
demons if you want to use the you know
christian you know nomenclature yeah
there's demons out there it's like well
we can't do anything about that so we're
just going to try to appease them so
they won't [ __ ] with us yes they won't
do which like i said that's that's
totally illegitimate we'll sacrifice
these five children if you don't [ __ ]
with these other 400 [ __ ] 500 600
children that we have here that's that's
what they were doing but the the spanish
were appalled back in the 1500s but they
didn't understand the system they didn't
have the literature they didn't know the
thinking that well
well and i feel like a lot of cortes
yeah i mean there's nothing he could do
i mean you don't want to like blanket
because i'm because there were like some
people even back then that was kind of
like bro like you know this is an actual
complex civilization with their own kind
of thing and maybe we should try to
understand it rather than just
destroying it right um but you know i
kind of feel like the overriding thing
was no just destroy it i don't want to
hear about it yeah i mean because
the mayans uh and and the mexican empire
or the aztec empire that was [ __ ]
laid layered on top of it where every
bit of what
japan was in the 14 15 16 1700s it was
about that same thing they were just
under a different condition
there was cannibalism and stuff but
there was trout and a lot of other there
was cannibalism in russia during world
war ii you know i mean that's what i
mean it's like i don't really think that
like one civilization yeah i don't know
if you can really get too high and
mighty about like oh well you guys can't
do this because you know everybody's got
like [ __ ] skeletons in their closet
yeah it's like you know times get hard
[ __ ]
gonna do he's got to do
and a lot of things are similar if you
look at him like through a particular
lens
i think people are get too hung up on
like but like i said maybe not so much
nowadays but i yeah i kind of feel like
people got too hung up on like the
differences and didn't really understand
like the similarities because a lot of
stuff is like really similar you're just
looking at it through a slightly
different lens that's all zach just
jumped in and said hello to us and said
uh we're a cult now yeah we've always
been a cult matter of fact where are
them damn super chats jenny [ __ ]
worked hard on this show it's not a
single super chat all day i mean we're
not a cult because i'm not like asking
you to like you know
disconnect from your family yeah we know
times are hard you all that you all have
to have sex with me and you can't do
anything
if i get some pictures of her you all
will want to have sex with her like
[ __ ] crazy i'll [ __ ] we'd make
thousands of dollars tens of thousands
we'd have them flying from all around
the world to come have sex with you
you think i think so
sure why not
that's [ __ ] funny
tom's trying to pimp me out i'm trying
to pimp
or is that good yeah let's get some more
ice this morning i mean you know all
right
if i ever need more ice yes i always
need more ice it's [ __ ] florida
that's what we do here
cult of pookie i i can agree with that
like i said
if you want to be a cult i don't want to
be like a shitty cult though i'm not i'm
you know i kind of want your money but
i'm not going to come and take it from
you i'm not going to like say i'm going
to like get give you like [ __ ] and
you know and i'm not gonna tell you what
to do
i'm not saying we have rules or nothing
like that it's just it's chill it's
chill it's the cult of chill do the [ __ ]
what you want if you want to send me
money that's cool yeah if you don't
that's okay too i understand i'm also
broke yeah we're all right so i get it
yeah
i did a world is falling apart i did
okay this month well i got a lot of
graphic design working this month which
was which helped
but you know what i mean so
uh maurice carrell made a study on the
maya that will blow your mind a couple
decades ago and honestly i mean
yeah yeah yeah
i mean honestly dude we did a show about
the maya did we not
no we needed to do more show we did one
a long time ago we did one a long time
that's how we got a lot of our mexican
fans
yeah um
kylo vasilen of course lives in tijuana
he's been a friend of mine
online friend of mine for [ __ ] years
now
one of the first fans that ever
contacted me if you're from southern
california for a certain part of my life
again you know what i mean and uh again
i ha i have an affinity towards you know
what i mean mexico and then growing up
partially in brazil i've been all over
this [ __ ] even though i'm
southern
okay my family
from the south mississippi
but
no man [ __ ] um
north americans do not appreciate
mesoamerican history
sadly yeah they don't they don't
appreciate it it's as cool as any
ancient egypt [ __ ] ancient rome they
had their own thing going it was it was
different it was a different conditions
but they were humans just like us
and they [ __ ] did some they had some
cool ideas
and one of the most advanced calendars
ever
um
and uh it's a lost civilization because
the vatican and the spanish burned a lot
of their history
and according to the spanish friars
yeah according to the spanish friars
it was a vast history
with a lot of poetry it would have
happened yeah they said it had a lot of
great poetry any culture that's been
around for that long of a time is going
to have like a wealth of culture
they said it was on par with greco-roman
culture
unfortunately destroyed
i mean the [ __ ] that survived is like
pretty badass though honestly you know
where you should go
is there's a museum in tampa i think
they changed the name since i've been
there but it's basically like the museum
of south florida or whatever the hell
they're calling it now i don't know but
they have like a massive massive or they
used to like when i lived there they had
a massive um
display of like uh
maya olmec
aztec they had all that kind of stuff
they had like a whole wing yeah and they
had like really they had like one of
those really big calendars you know i
mean like they had one of those i had i
took my picture in front of it like a
long time ago but yeah it's it's badass
they have like a a huge huge collection
yeah i don't know if a lot of it's still
out because that was a long time ago but
what the only the the average thing
mostly what a westerner or a north
northwesterner [ __ ] a white european
style person would know about it
it's what they
learned off the [ __ ] indiana jones
you just run around you got a big
[ __ ] golden [ __ ] face and [ __ ] no
it was a lot more than that there was a
lot of stuff that they believed in and
knew about
but it
it was part each thing that they had was
a part of a much larger culture that had
a lot we don't have the context yeah of
a lot of the stuff that they believed in
but they were not
a primitive people they were in advance
they were like the japanese they were
like you know
and it would be [ __ ] it's sadly
destroyed
by uh
the vatican vatican said no burn it it's
devil worship stuff we gotta make them
catholics
and then it kind of merged
the nahadol or the [ __ ] mashika
culture the mesoamerican culture and
catholicism they did or they had a lot
in common even back in those days yeah
sure there was a lot of stuff about the
uh about the mashika culture that was
kind of like catholicism
and not that like i said not that
different so it's like they saw that and
they're like oh yeah i get that yeah so
it's a little bit different but i get it
right but
just something lost a time unfortunately
it'd be interesting to know more about
exactly their literature and their
stories
you know
we finally picked apart the calendar and
the language
uh but it was it was a [ __ ] desert
jungle
type
culture that was
as cool as ancient egypt ancient rome
you know
pretty [ __ ] cool yeah it's weird
because i feel like it's i mean i'm glad
it's more getting it's due nowadays but
when i
i mean when we were growing up probably
like when i was in school i remember
like learning pretty much zero yeah
about that yeah i mean when you took a
world history class yeah i think it was
almost all european history i took a
whole year i took a whole world history
class yeah
um
in high school
and i'm pretty sure it was 90 95
european history yeah i don't even think
they covered any asian history i don't
think they covered any african history
yeah other than like ancient egypt and
[ __ ]
they didn't cover any of that yeah
nothing and uh you know growing up as a
teenager in brazil you run into uh in
what they would call indigenous people i
hate that word because it puts people in
boxes to me everybody's an american
there's new americans and old americans
and a lot of those old americans like
you look at old mex a lot of those they
don't look like they were from here they
were from africa okay
or something from some island somewhere
in polynesia
and honestly i never people have been
coming people have been coming here for
thousands and thousands well the thing
about
where you're from is maybe the least
important thing about you because you
didn't choose it right it's just you
just happened to be born where your
parents were at the time you were born
i mean you didn't have any control over
it with the central central and south
american people uh were a good-looking
people
good-looking people uh they always had
had a caste system
of elites and workers they were kind of
like ant colonies and like any others
all civilizations are kind of like ant
colonies but they were like that you
know what i mean and
uh they weren't any different from us
you know they were different but they
had their own character but i'm saying
that you everything is recognizable
you're looking oh yeah and
there's always the universal concept of
beauty
you know what i mean they had beautiful
people and people that were average and
people that were not not all that good
looking that's everywhere you know what
i mean
every culture has their homeland they
have their homely people
it's just this is everywhere you know
what i mean we're homely americans
that's just the reality you know
didn't matter what condom that's gonna
be my hyphenate i'm not homely just
happy
but uh no man [ __ ] uh
i had a good time growing up there and
[ __ ] you know what i mean and uh
got an appreciation that you know i'm
i'm too i mean i'm middle-aged i'm just
glad that i had the experience to come
up in brazil
and be able to see
argentina and chile and paraguay and
uruguay and go up into colombia
and you know and see uh
you know
[ __ ]
southern california which is kind of
like north mexico really you know and uh
grew up around uh friends that were
mexican-american or um
or uh
[ __ ] um
they're mexican-americans but they're
also mixed with irish people for chicano
people so we would call them in in in uh
in california
there's just
i'm just i'm just glad that i got to see
that part of the world you know
so i can because it was fun
it was fun it's not any kind of gravitas
or anything it's just you know you're
experiencing other people you know and
uh hanging out with them and learning
how to kind of vaseline [ __ ] send me
all kinds of [ __ ] recipes you know
i'm making my own tortillas [ __ ]
with out of my sacka and [ __ ] making
my growing my own [ __ ] chilies to
make [ __ ] salsa and [ __ ] you know
because you know being a cook you have
to [ __ ] incorporate everything but
then i'll
[ __ ]
mix british [ __ ] in there too
and european stuff too you know a lot of
the stuff that we have here in the south
you know like chicken fries steak
southern fried steak
that's schnitzel that's wiener schnitzel
which is german you know we do that too
you know
country gravy
just the world's a [ __ ] great place i
just hope you guys enjoy it you know
it's a great place
and the world has a lot of different
kinds of people they're all cool
you know
they're all i mean 90 99 of people are
cool yeah you always gotta watch for
that one percent that are like serial
killers and [ __ ] you got [ __ ] and
there's [ __ ] dumb [ __ ]
right but super cool most people are
okay like they might not be cool cool
like like hey i want to hang out with
you cool
but most people are just like okay like
not like harmless you know what i mean i
kind of feel like i don't want to be
like one of those people because i know
like some people get like that when they
get older just like oh my god everybody
is the worst and stuff everybody like
people suck and everything like that
they don't suck
most people are fine yeah most people
are inoffensive
most people are inoffensive yeah you
know what i mean just seriously most
people wouldn't they'd they're not going
to hurt you nothing like that now you
got to watch your ass but you know what
i mean because you never know but khan's
going off about montezuma's [ __ ]
problems that he didn't kill cortez
[ __ ] earlier no look you can't look
at it that way what happened happened
and what happened with mexico happened
and that was where mexico's character
came from mexico is a place almost kind
of like texas
where it's a mixture
of mesoamerican and european okay it's
just that's what happened
you can't reverse what happened
you know
but the thing is though is that even if
even if montezuma killed cortez at a
certain time
it wouldn't have helped because later on
more spanish would have come and it just
would happen later
world changes
and that was the way the world was going
it would have been an unstoppable
or no way to it would have always been
the blend
it would have always been that bland
god it's a blessing like a spice yeah
and i look at you a [ __ ] [ __ ] car
that's got some spanish bloodlines in
his ass anyway look at that big
[ __ ]
you're an elite mexican with spanish
little bloodlines you know it bro
you're too tall you're too tall and good
looking
hold on
because
the only tall mexicans were the mexicans
that were not sacrificed
okay that's how the mashiki did that
[ __ ]
[ __ ] the underclass got sacrificed
the royal class didn't
okay
you know you you know you were you're
royal
too big to be running the mexican
danny rowling said uh jenny what
mystical ways did this emperor seek out
to be immortal again uh
mostly he kind of went along he any kind
of legend that came around about oh
there's this mystical like [ __ ]
wizard or whatever or these islands or
whatever like he would go and try to
find that [ __ ] it was almost like pasta
leon looking for the fountain of youth
kind of situation and like i said he
either drank mercury or took mercury
tablets because somebody not sure who
told him that mercury was like an elixir
of life he was always kind of like
looking for an elixir of life uh spoiler
alert the mercury uh killed him
that's what they think anyway and he
didn't live that long like i said he was
only 49 or 50 when he died and probably
it was from all the mercury that he
drank because he thought that it would
make him live forever
he didn't know any better i mean you
know i laugh but
you know what's he gonna do he's been
dead for thousands of years he's not
gonna like come back and get me it's
fine
um
let's see zach says kind of weird for a
topic but you guys should do a show
about the tomb raider games or movies
lyric lara croft and her exploits fit
the show pretty well honestly you know
what that's not that crazy i was kind of
like i've never played them but i
watched tom play them a lot because he
really likes them but i don't think i've
ever seen the movies though now that i'm
thinking about it but i like the games i
like any of that kind of like
when i was a kid i don't remember if i
ever brought this up on the show before
when i was a kid i wanted to be an
archaeologist big time
like up until i was about
well i think when i was really little i
wanted to be a veterinarian and like i
said uh until i figured out that it's
like what i'd have to put like kitties
and doggies to sleep no thank you and
then um i was like i think i'll be an
archaeologist instead
and honestly i wouldn't mind doing that
nowadays that seems like a kind of a
cool job
ian england says uh tom and jenny glad i
got to join in again i moved in june and
didn't have internet until now holy [ __ ]
uh love y'all in the podcast well hey we
love you too we're glad you're back yeah
i thought i hadn't seen you in a little
while i mean it's been a month but you
know moving i know
um kanavatsan says i love angelina jolie
in that role she does actually kind of
i mean she looks a lot like the game
character i think they did like really
good casting there but i don't think
i've ever seen any of the movies now
that i'm thinking about it
maybe i saw the first one i can't really
remember
i just i like the game so much that
i don't think have you seen any of the
tomb raider movies yeah i've seen like
the first two they were okay they were
okay they were fine i like the games
better
that's what i'm saying i just like the
games i like watching you play the game
oh yeah [ __ ] uh although every time
you're like climbing around like some
big like [ __ ] bottomless pit or
something like that it makes me so i
played the classic
legend anxiety
was big into like legend and um what was
the other one tomb raider
[ __ ] i don't remember all the names
of it was like [ __ ] dark angel or
something there was like [ __ ] four or
five of them the older ones from the 90s
i liked those
yeah like i said they're and they're
really relaxing well other good music
playing yeah i like the music and i like
all the puzzles anniversary was one of
them that i played now they got a whole
bunch of new ones
which they have a different character
she isn't quite thank you ian thank you
she's not quite as drawn the same way
she's not as voluptuous and more
idealized but i like the old [ __ ]
laura chris you liked when she was
bouncy bouncing she was not as balanced
as you think
she was but she was just kind of like
yeah she definitely had implants she had
implants
but she was the first i'm climbing up on
these [ __ ] like walls of this temple
and it's like with my boobs bouncing
yeah and she and she's if i was her i
would have put on a sports bra you know
she probably had one on but uh she had
she was uh it was a good character and
she's uh part i think spanish and
british i think uh
in the game
and um
the puzzles are great and jumping around
i think it was anniversary legend i
think it was some other dark something
dark angel i think it was a pc game but
i was able to get that for [ __ ] xbox
one
um
and then there was a newer one that i
played that's really good
uh that's probably from like 2010 2005
around that i don't remember which one
that one was called
uh that's where she's doing all the
mesoamerican stuff and [ __ ] doing the
sun dials and
i don't know i gotta play that [ __ ]
again i remember you playing
and then she ends up being underwater
with a bunch of [ __ ] norse big old
noises that's right i remember watching
you play that yeah that was a really
good i don't remember what it was called
though yeah
but they're fun games you know i haven't
played the new ones there's a lot of new
ones out there but they they look too
realistic to me i like idealized video
game type stuff
i think i've had some
subscribers say no play the new ones
you'll like them
but you know i don't know
maybe i will there's something about the
music from the old ones and the kind of
the relaxing pace
where you're going through like you go
to croft manor
and you're playing around inside the
[ __ ] the the
mansion
you're in the mansion and then you're in
the [ __ ]
of the maze made of the hedges and try
to find [ __ ] little
[ __ ]
silver and gold coins to
like level yourself up and [ __ ] just fun
[ __ ] you know
zack says archaeology seems like kind of
a glamorous career but uh if you've ever
seen time team it actually seems pretty
boring yeah i kind of thought that like
i think a lot of people got like a
romanticized version of it because of
the indiana jones movies yeah um in the
80s and then like the
tomb raider games later on but most of
the time yeah you're just like sitting
in some hot ass desert somewhere like
with a little brush like trying to like
pick out some [ __ ] bones but i don't
know there's i
something there's something like really
relaxing and like kind of interesting
about that so zac
asking about [ __ ] tomb raider says we
should do something on the games he says
it was called angel of darkness
2003. yeah he said it was kind of a
piece of [ __ ] because they released it
half finished because of the deadlines
and it almost tanked the series yeah but
the thing is though is that i got it on
xbox one and there's a bunch of [ __ ] you
could unlock which expanded the game
i from what i never had a discs or
anything and i liked it i liked it
um i don't remember that one i remember
you playing legend and i remember
anniversary anniversary and then there
was another one um
that was newer
it was good but she started off as she's
on her boat
and you guys oh yeah yeah yeah yeah and
the water effects are really good
now count goes yeah true i guess he's
talking about me
just i just still don't like the
spaniards
so i love angelina jolie in that role
she said archaeology seems zack's
talking about
yeah the archaeology seems glamorous but
it's not well it's not it's not
glamorous it just seems well yeah that's
right
most of the time you're just like
sitting there like
yeah
very meticulously like
picking like bones out of the dirt yeah
yeah the concepts i played the new ones
but lara is so skinny she needs some
bouncy action yeah
she just doesn't look like lara croft
laura croft was a skinny james bond
female basically with implants and
a [ __ ] sexy
[ __ ] walk and um good with guns and
with a british accent and she's
basically james bond she's just the
female jay's bond and she's also
just a [ __ ]
a thief
going into damn tombs yeah so
in a way she's not only she james bond
she's also also kind of like [ __ ]
indiana jones yeah yeah which i thought
was a great character and they tried to
kind of in the newer ones it's kind of
like they tried to make her a normal
person like no no
no laura croft was not a normal person
she was like james bond she was an icon
you know which is kind of like a
superhero you know
i mean honestly i don't like play a lot
of video games myself but the ones that
i used to enjoy watching you play
was the tomb raider games and fallout
yeah because of the music
yeah i think it's just very relaxed and
i kind of like i don't really like
games that are just kind of like coming
at you like all the time with like all
this noise and action i'm just like look
i don't my anxiety doesn't need that i
like tomb raider because
yeah some of it's anxiety inducing
especially like me because i'm afraid of
heights and stuff so it's like whenever
he's jumping around in big ten there's
like big gaps i'm like holy [ __ ] i'm
like freaking out but
the music is relaxing and a lot of times
you can just kind of like take your time
yeah you're not underneath and i like
like i said in fallout it's kind of the
same thing it's like hey i'm just gonna
dick around in my yeah
in my shelter for a little while like
decorate things and make it i'm going to
put rugs down yeah yeah like i just i
like that you can kind of like take
things at your own pace and it's not
just this constant thing it's like oh my
god somebody's shooting at me oh my god
it's monsters
you can make an underground fallout
shelter and build stand-up arcade video
games yeah play a video game inside of a
video game i will you know
i would sit there and like for like two
three hours and just like watch him
decorate his apartment
i don't really care about him like
shooting at the like giant monsters or
nothing like that i'm like yeah that's
cool and everything but it's like i was
like ooh get that like post that's cool
like put that put that rug over there
you know what i mean it was like that
kind of stuff i like stuff where you can
like go at [ __ ] it's like well okay now
i'm ready to go fight some monsters so
i'm gonna go out my apartment i'm gonna
go fight some monsters and go on a
mission and but you can like do it at
your own pace i like that i like that
and i think a lot of people do kind of
like like that idea which is probably
why the game's so popular yeah um yeah
kind of odson said fallout is awesome
man i still play that yeah yeah i like
all the fallout games i like all that i
still haven't done even all the
expansion stuff off
expansive that game is there's just like
so much stuff and like yeah like you've
done even like a lot of the side
missions and you haven't like done like
a percentage of the [ __ ] no i haven't
been on i haven't played it in about a
month i said i need to go what was the
one that you had that has like all i
think it's like set around isn't it set
around like dc and boston and stuff so
it's up like all around kind of like the
colonial era fallout [ __ ] what was it
for
i like that like i liked that i know
that area i lived in that area the
[ __ ] well yeah that's what i'm saying
it's wrong though it doesn't look like
that that's okay it's a video game yeah
are we uh still on the show are you done
no i'm done yeah okay so we're winding
down uh and you guys said i played
fallout vegas which was pretty cool yeah
yeah vegas i like the new vegas yeah
yeah yeah and that had it had it had
howard hughes in it
that's right had howard hughes in his
house how about that
he was in suspended animation i wouldn't
mind playing new vegas again
ian said uh if you have fallout 4 you
need to get the far harbor yeah i'm on
far harbor yeah i think he's playing
that now i haven't gone to i think
after far harbor i think the other one
is like robotron or robo something or
other i got to do that one after that
i'm on far harbor
zach says i'm friends on facebook with
peter connolly who did the music for the
90s games tom you should reach out to
him he's awesome what might i do with
him
i'm i'm straight you're just like you
you mean [ __ ] zach could blow it well
you can like talk to him about is what
okay yeah he did he did uh the laura
croft games because the laura croft
music game the laura croft music so
relax that [ __ ] would be played at my
funeral
into
no you know what at your funeral you
know what i'm gonna play i don't know
i'm gonna play a haunting theme yeah
[Laughter]
and i'm gonna have like that dude is
that dude still alive what's that dude's
name i know i know his name but i can't
think of it he i know what his name is
but i can't think of it anthony
something anthony call is that what his
name is um but yeah so i'm going to have
him do the voice over at your funeral
can i can i do that zach's ass that
would be simple
noir no i haven't i don't even know
anything about that one
i don't know anything about them says
one of his favorite games
every now i'm always just kind of like
man i should get into video games i
should never do i feel like i never have
time
yeah i feel like i've never heard you're
working all the time
and now that i've started now that i
have like
if if anyone's counting now that i have
three [ __ ] separate channels going
yeah and it's like so every single day
i'm like oh i gotta make a video for
this channel or i gotta like so i feel
like i never have yeah you see
because of everything that's happening
you know internet money's starting to
dry up so we have to try to expand
a footprint to keep up with this [ __ ]
unfortunately i mean jenny still does
good on the books and the graphic design
but
internet money's drying up well i
thought to myself that
maybe because i mean i know that we have
a lot like quite a lot of subscribers on
13 o'clock but i thought to myself maybe
there's another audience that um
you know would maybe like this show but
it's a little bit scatter shot because
like i said we didn't plan anything from
the start so it was just kind of like
all over the place and we're like
whatever the [ __ ] we feel like talking
about which is good i like that but i
said well maybe i should start like a
couple other channels that are more
focused yeah um that maybe would like
draw on some people that wouldn't
normally watch this [ __ ] because it's
like what why the [ __ ] are you guys like
yapping about [ __ ] that doesn't have
anything to do with what you're supposed
to be talking about so i was just kind
of like
so i thought that i would do that and i
said well it doesn't really take me i
mean it takes a long time but it doesn't
take that much longer
to do
like a couple more videos a week than i
have been doing and the only thing i can
do is like
i could do survivalist stuff and cooking
stuff that's
which maybe you should maybe you should
do you want to put it on the same ring
of channels
i don't know i mean you can if you want
like you have to film it for me oh geez
i don't have time for that yes that's
the problem well if i could put it up on
a damn well um
no i still have dropbox don't we yeah so
that means i can record it through i
mean you could record it on your [ __ ]
and then just send me the file because
we have a shared dropbox so you could
just like send it through there
and then like i could put it up i'm not
going to edit it or nothing jesus christ
how much time do you think i have right
like i said well you i would make it so
you wouldn't have to edit it that's what
i'm saying yeah that's what i'm saying
right but you know and the thing about
it is like i don't yeah [ __ ] ian
lane england's is when i'm gonna start
my own podcast
i don't think i would have to it would
be easier for me to just make videos
and [ __ ] send them to our dropbox and
her put them up
and i could even put them i could even
put them in a separate playlist or i
could start another channel because like
i said when i first started doing like
flickers of fear tones of tara like my
other uh you know movie and book reviews
that are just me i was like well should
i start a new channel i said well
initially i'll just start a new playlist
right but i think
eventually i'll move those to the to the
horror channel right but i'm not going
to do it right now because the horror
channel i can't monetize it yet because
it's too small the thing is though is if
i do
more survivalist
type stuff
it wouldn't be interactive unless i
streamed it
and i wouldn't make any money unless i
streamed it
so i'd have to stream it
well i mean you could eventually get
your own laptop and stream it through
there i have a laptop over there i don't
know oh that's right i don't know if
that laptop is good enough that's my old
one yeah we didn't we have problems
streaming with that or was that our
connection i think that was our
connection you might actually be fine
because you know now that we have do we
still have a way i can physically
connect to this
uh yeah yeah i have that right yeah yeah
i think yeah you can yeah i have a land
cable right there
look what i could try to do is i could
try to [ __ ] stream something
yeah you could try we'll do an
experimental stream
i'll tell you all about it when it when
it's ready
or like can i do it on another channel
if you wanted to come in here and stream
you could no i want to be around where
all my equipment stuff we're all
in your man yeah yeah we're going to
show you what i'm showing what i'm
talking about
yeah let's see if you can i mean that's
how it is but like i said you continue
to work
yeah right
i'm just saying if you needed to i could
work around you but i'm just saying we
had to talk more about it yeah see
exactly what it is i have to have to do
to set it up yeah like i said just don't
like
i i don't really have like a lot of time
to like like i said if you want to make
videos and stuff i don't have a lot of
time no
it makes more sense if i stream it
kind of odd so it says live from the man
cave
[Laughter]
yeah well that way we can hear your man
cave is literally i would do it i would
do it so we could interact yeah
if i can interact then i can answer
questions and it would help me move
along through the whole [ __ ] thing
but i have to get it set up with you
guys
you know i could cover all kinds of
stuff equipment
combo which
communication uh [ __ ]
current events
everything that's happening
with uh you know
global politics or [ __ ] uh what do
you call it
[ __ ] geopolitics
a lot of weird shit's happening and i
could also recommend other channels
that are more precise than me that are
actually [ __ ] working on [ __ ] and
actually have receipts to what we're
talking about
but you know i could do that
i could do that and then we could
discuss [ __ ] but i'm mostly into like uh
what exact equipment you need how do you
maintain it and what what is good for
what
the guy dudes [ __ ] doing crazy [ __ ]
like buying
plate carriers and [ __ ] they don't
even know what that's for they just
[ __ ] saw
soldiers carrying that and they don't
understand the limit the bonuses and the
limitations of something like that it's
only for certain things you know i have
a plate carrier
i wouldn't try to live in a play carrier
crazy no
no it's only good for certain things
so i said love your red hair jenny thank
you
oh i forgot to tell you i also i got a
new you know the blue wig that i love so
much yeah i bought another one just like
that yeah just because the one that i
had before was getting kind of like a
little bit yeah tangly and janky because
i wear it out all the time so i got
another one just like that when's the
next uh memento mori
it might be this friday this friday okay
because i i want to go out
i'm getting sick of this [ __ ] it might
be friday but i'll check okay with
dimitri i think it's this friday good
and so we might so which means we'd have
to go like after the show right i will
i'll do it so you're gonna have to
behave because i'm gonna have to not
drink i don't want to have to drive home
again last time i was [ __ ] up bob wow
were you guys here like did you hear
that story should we tell that story
again go ahead and tell it yeah
i got pictures now too okay
wait pictures of what
[ __ ] scott sent me pictures of his
[ __ ] girlfriend [ __ ] that was that
that that was there that was [ __ ]
with me
i got pictures of that now
i have a feeling that there was more to
that than usual there was i oh i got the
whole [ __ ] backstory i got the whole
[ __ ] backstory no i mean i think
there was more to that than you told me
what do you mean
i think that was what do you think me
and her me and her were [ __ ] around
no i don't know i'm just saying that i'm
just saying i think there was more to
that than you told me well you were like
super super drunk that night though yeah
yeah what enough happening we didn't go
out after the show like last week we
went out saturday
we went to barbarella
and it was a good night it's that's the
80s night like new wave and stuff
and so we went there
and uh i barely drank yeah um i had two
of those like [ __ ]
white claw type things and i think i
drank those things like before 10 30 and
we didn't leave until almost two i was
so pounding those [ __ ] things and he
didn't
they don't even have liquor no okay they
don't have hard liquor they just have
like white cloth [ __ ] they have beer
uh and that's about it uh well they they
have no they have a bunch of different
flavors one was mojito
i had one of those mojito i was drinking
those things like it was water
because i thought they were so weak i
got [ __ ] hammered i haven't seen you
that hammered in a long time because i'm
chugging them i was chugging them and
throwing them oh they're so weak it's
like five percent alcohol well yeah but
five percent that adds up that adds up
real fast like i said me i had one of
those bacardi mojito things when we
first got there and that was 9 30. and
then i had one like it wasn't white claw
but it was like a white claw i don't
remember what brand it was but it was
like it was watermelon watermelon yeah i
had that about 10 30. after that i drank
no more i'd write nothing but water
until we left and it was almost two
tom was
hammered i was hammered
so hammered that like we left and our
friend sophie was like please tell me
that you're driving jenny because he was
just like he was blah
blah blah he was just like yelling and
he just like kept yelling the same
things at me and i was like dude you
told me that like 20 times already like
he kept telling me the same thing and he
was like yelling and i was like oh my
god so everyone's just like please tell
me you're driving and for a second he's
like i can drive i can drive him like
seriously and then like so he gets in
the car and he backs immediately into
another car backs
like it didn't hurt our car it didn't
hurt there was just bumpers but yeah
it's like he just and i was like get out
no no no no no no actually he drove down
for a little while he drove well you
drove like a block about a block and and
i couldn't see and you were like you
were weaving and i was like pull over
right now yeah because i was sober and i
was like i just didn't want to drive
because i was like man i got to take
these [ __ ] shoes off because i can't
drive in those boots but i was just like
you're going to kill me please get out
so so i made him get out
and so i had to drive home because he
was so [ __ ] up
he was really really [ __ ] up and then
like the whole time like i said well can
you navigate because i have my phone i
don't remember how to get home because
of all the toll roads and stuff because
we don't go there that often so uh but
so he kept reading to me 2.5 miles two
points i'm like dude it's fine like
she'll tell me like when the turn's
coming up you don't have to tell me like
every point
we did well yeah because i was sober
yeah and so i was driving and so then
like we i stopped at the circle k so he
could run i said you got to go and get
some sandwiches because i don't have my
shoes on so i can't drive those boots on
so he went in and got some sandwiches
and that was fine so we get home
i have a chicken salad sandwich he has a
couple burritos that he can't eat or
whatever no i ate them
no i thought you that was that one you
didn't eat because you were like i can't
eat it i didn't finish it there's only
one third of it left and then
and then like we go to sleep and it was
probably like three o'clock in the
morning
then like an hour later i think it was
like an hour hour and a half later
i didn't hear i don't think i heard
anything yeah but i just suddenly woke
up and i was like something weird is
happening
and i turned and i was because i was
laying this way like away from the door
of the bedroom and i turned around and i
see like in the room it's kind of dark
but i can still see because of the light
from the hall
and i turn and i see tom
standing
at the end of the bed
like because at the end of the bed we
have like this big long bench thing it's
like a bench that you can lift up and
you push it in it yeah that he sits on
sometimes and it's like so he was
standing by that and he was just
standing there and like not moving and
it was like it was really creepy and i
was like i looked at it like that and i
was like
what are you doing because like i said i
was so buried he was still [ __ ] up
because this was only like an hour an
hour and a half later after you'd gone
to sleep yeah
so i'm like what are you doing and he
says pissing
yeah
i was like are you peeing on the floor
yeah
and then he like and then he's like what
where what like where am i like he's
been sleepwalking i was sleepwalking and
i was just like holy [ __ ] did you just
[ __ ] pee on the floor yeah i'm
[ __ ] reaching around trying to find
it i couldn't find it i didn't piss i
was i was dreaming that it was this is
[ __ ] fun i have never seen that
happen ever no and then like just i was
just like oh my god i was like please
don't
scream it on the floor i was dreaming
that i was in the bathroom taking a leak
but i wasn't [ __ ] taking a leak and i
wasn't in the basement it's totally crap
yeah it was [ __ ]
it was just that was so weird though
like me turn it over like that and just
see you standing i said he looked just
like the [ __ ] chick in paranormal
activity
and we don't know how long he'd been
standing there just like i may have been
standing there long time
but [ __ ] what happened before that
[ __ ] night
which was funny i thought this [ __ ] was
funny
my friend scott
showed up
with the [ __ ] um
with a trans woman with a trans girl
and
the trans girl me and trans girl we're
talking and she's freaking
loving on me so i go to the bathroom and
that and she comes in after me and she's
almost suck your dick and [ __ ] i'm
like no no no no no she's loving her i
said i don't know i got a girlfriend and
she goes yeah i know she's here but i'm
gonna go through proper channels i said
you need to go through property she's
gonna go through proper channels you get
good so you can go talk to her first
before you suck this dick and she's like
you i love you you know i kind of you're
the greatest man ever [ __ ] because
she thought that i was just gonna
[ __ ] let her
i said you go talk to her she was trying
to get me involved in which yeah she was
she was like i'm bisexual i'll [ __ ] her
too and i said go talk to her
[Laughter]
but this is who it is she was telling me
that well she she was wanting me to get
into like involved in like some [ __ ]
witchcraft yeah she was she was trying
to involve me in witchcraft yeah that's
her
that we were gonna do that we were gonna
do some like witchcraft right and she
was certain yeah and she was there with
my friend
so you know that that that
i'd actually i've never seen her before
actually her name was yeah and i had
actually never seen her before yeah yeah
um i guess he had uh what happened to
what happened okay i'll tell you how
that [ __ ] happened
are you gonna tell me yeah i was like
where the [ __ ] did you meet her because
we've known him forever and he's got a
girlfriend i've known scotty's
well not girlfriend fiance yeah
scott yeah what happened to her scott's
got a wife in in the married door well
they were engaged to be married i think
i don't know i don't remember if they
got married or not but i know they were
engaged
now i can do whatever i want she told me
that i can do whatever i want as long as
i come home at night
say so scott i kind of figured that it
was something like that all right
scott goes on a dating site okay looking
for
i guess you could i don't want to call
them escorts but they're kind of like
they're kind of like escorts
and he found her
yeah so she was escort
okay a novice escort
okay
and
that was his secretary for the night
okay you know it's [ __ ] it was like a
paid date
okay i gotcha that's what was going on
here i gotcha
but she didn't like him
he says he's not [ __ ] he's like i
don't think i'm gonna [ __ ] call her
out i'm not gonna [ __ ] take her out
anymore
he's got a girlfriend but that was his
little secretary for the night
that's a i had to think people outside i
don't know i don't know if people
outside the scene would understand it um
scott isn't this guy's a [ __ ] hoe
okay scott's a hoe scott's always we
like scotty though she is scottish it's
funny because god owns a bar yeah yeah
he owns another bar downtown called the
capitol room yeah he looks he looks like
a regular
guy like he doesn't look
gothy no he's like a he's like a jock
but he's super into
he's been going to ibar since yeah
forever yeah i mean probably longer than
i've been going and i've been going a
long time so yeah he's been going there
forever he's
older than me but i think he's younger
than me
and he's [ __ ] he's 50ish
52
51 something like that i think he's a
little bit older than i am but he's
younger than you are yeah so but yeah
he's been going there forever like i
said he looks normal he just looks like
a regular guy but he's super super into
like 80s music and like god music and
stuff like that you wouldn't know it
looking at him but
um yeah but he owns a bar he has a lot
of money so he owns a bar
him and um big tom who owns mannequins
they
have a thing going so
he you know they have like kind of a
business partnership a little bit so
scotty bought a bar called the capitol
room which i think is going to open next
month because i did the posters for it
um it's kind of more he's not
necessarily competing with mannequins
because it's more like a high-end he
wants it to be kind of like a great
gatsby
kind of
20s ish
kind of vibe like i said like roll
high-end martinis like that kind of
stuff
but then he wants to do
because like the poster i did like one
of the opening things he wants to do was
like a cbgb night where he plays like
blondie and the ramones and talking
heads and stuff like that so he wants
kind of like a hybrid
so that's kind of like what he's doing
with that but yeah so he came to
barbarella saturday night um which like
i said not unusual because he's there
pretty much every saturday but yeah i
was because sometimes he brings his
fiance
um
but sometimes a lot of times she doesn't
come so a lot of times he comes by
himself so this was i think the first
time and we haven't been out for a while
but i think this is the first time that
i'd seen him like bring somebody else
yeah um and i kind of figured because i
was like oh well probably they have like
an open relationship thing yeah cause
that's very because that's pretty cool
yeah but um
yeah so i kind of figured that out scott
scott said he wasn't gonna go out with
her anymore because
one she's married to a woman and they
have a kid
oh okay she didn't tell me that no no
that transsexual is a father
okay i got you and
when he
brought her home
a big fight happened out in front of the
house about where the [ __ ] were you and
all those because
he was like and she's like i'm trying to
get away from you i went out with skye
i'm trying to get away with you i'm sick
of you and they're two months behind in
rent and all that kind of [ __ ] and
[ __ ] scott
didn't like that she was [ __ ] yelling
yelling at the mother of her child
i'm trying to get the [ __ ] pronouns
correct
that she's that she's yelling at the
mother of her child
and uh he didn't like how sh and he was
like oh okay that's what's going on here
i'm not going out with her anymore
well the thing about it was that as soon
as she got there she seemed like to hone
in on me and tom well yeah she didn't
want to be with scott we talked about
and
man she was just she was trying to like
[ __ ] get all up in the middle of it
yeah she's trying to get up in that
like i said she was trying to like
recruit me into a witchcraft yeah she
was uh she's a bisexual trans
transsexual
yeah yeah and she just kept telling me
she's like yeah she said she's so high
yeah she was like i'm gonna [ __ ] your
girlfriend and i said i said oh you
gonna [ __ ] my girlfriend
[ __ ] her you're gonna get your [ __ ]
[ __ ] back busted up
although i think i don't know you know
maybe jenny might be up for that
i'm not really sure but i was like yeah
okay man
she was cool though she was cool i liked
her she was fine she's a little weird
about that yeah well she was desperate
desperate
yeah she was good because i was just
kind of well the thing about it is that
um
i have a lot of and i think and i don't
really know if like this is
what people think but i think sometimes
maybe
that people and i only know this from
people that like i
didn't know and like i met later and
they told me what they thought
but they thought when they first met me
they were talking i mean you showed that
and i'm gonna show the other one you
said that earlier that's the other photo
okay yeah that's her yeah that's her so
yeah so the thing about it was that
i kind of feel like maybe some people
that don't man look what you did
did i [ __ ] it up yeah what did you do i
don't know
how did you do that i guess it was
because the uh it was so light what
happened hold your hand over it well
yeah but
what the [ __ ] man what did you do you
really needed a quick broken you need to
quit doing this
yeah thanks a lot so now i'm in the
[ __ ] dark
yeah thanks
what else is new he's gonna make let me
deal with it
why did you [ __ ] it up like that why did
you do it
oh my god why
why
anyway
even though you can't [ __ ] see me
but
uh what happened i think that a lot of
people thought that i was
um
a snot
you know what i mean because
i don't talk a lot in the club but it's
because i don't talk a lot because i
can't [ __ ] hear anything
i can't [ __ ] hear anything so
some people want to come in and like
they want to have these big long social
conversations and i'm like [ __ ] i can't
hear a [ __ ] word you're saying and
it's like i don't want to be rude and
like sit there and be like
what what what like every five seconds
so i usually like i'm just like look i'm
just here to dance i can't have big long
conversations i'm not trying to be like
snotty or aloof or anything like that
it's just i can't hear you
i can't how did he do that
i don't understand like what the [ __ ]
i i've told him a million times i was
like please don't hold that [ __ ] up to
the camera because it messes up the
focus and it messes up the lighting and
he just keeps doing it anyway and i
don't understand like why
i mean everything's all the lights are
still on
all the lights are still on my ring
light's still on everything's still on
i don't know what the [ __ ] he did
i don't know what the [ __ ] he did
um
i'm just gonna wait till he comes back
in i'm just like i'm just gonna this is
this is driving me crazy because
ian says i feel your pain johnny i'm
deaf as [ __ ] yeah me too and it's just
kind of like i don't because i kind of
feel like it's it causes a lot of
anxiety because people will be like
talking to them having these big
elaborate conversations about who knows
what i mean it could be something like
really important look what you did but
how do i oh i'm gonna fix this [ __ ]
i've been doing that the whole time
you've been going it didn't work huh no
what happened okay i'm gonna do it again
hold on
what how did you i keep telling you like
please stop moving this stuff in front
of please stop putting stuff in front of
the camera
it's just like see if i can get it and
see if i can get it to [ __ ] read it
messes everything up
sorry we're towards the end of the show
and everything's [ __ ] dark
i can't understand it
but yeah
but that's the thing so people have
these big like comments and you know for
all i know re-do it with that right well
that was a boob so that was the one that
did it no
why don't you boobs okay
i mean i didn't fix it you've got me
like demonetized like so many times it's
just like without your [ __ ] the [ __ ]
that you're showing but yeah it's like
just just please stop doing that well
just finish it up and then we'll yeah
we'll shut it but what i was saying is
like people have these big elaborate
conversations like they could be like
pouring out their heart to me but i
don't really know because and i feel
really bad because it's like i can't
hear a [ __ ] word you're saying and i
don't really want to like stand there
and be like what what what and it's like
because i just feel like an [ __ ] so
i'm just like it's better to just not
talk
like don't get any complicated
i mean if you want to talk let's like go
outside or
you know we'll go get coffee or
something like that where i can actually
[ __ ] hear what you're saying
not when there's music blaring in the
background yeah you know what i mean um
yeah jeffy said i can sort of see yeah
this is pissing me off this darkness so
i broke some [ __ ] yeah yeah you did
yeah i mean you obviously broke it i
have never seen that happen
i have never seen that happen ian said
just smile and wave yeah that's what i
do i'm just like yeah whatever
hopefully they didn't tell me anything
bad like their [ __ ] mom just died or
something like that and i'm just like
yep cool
i don't know i kind of i i have a i have
a paranoid
that that's going to happen because i
was like i have no idea what you said
but i like to like pretend that i that i
can hear people
zack said what happened yeah what do you
think happened like tom held some [ __ ]
up to the camera and like [ __ ] up the
lighting and hopefully it doesn't stay
like this cause i have no idea i've
never seen this happen before ever i've
seen it actually go brighter
and then if i hold my hand up then like
sometimes it'll refocus but it doesn't
seem to be working this time and i
really don't know what happened so uh
yeah great yeah i just [ __ ]
end the show anyway
yeah i mean you know i don't understand
what the hell happened you [ __ ] it up
is what happened yeah i broke it yeah
you [ __ ] it up i broke it it does kind
of fit the mood of the show yeah we're
just going to like
here in the dark anyway thank you
everybody for dropping by this evening
hopefully you had a good time we'll be
back on friday night doing our uh
regularly scheduled
drunken ass track show yeah that should
be really fun yeah uh so yeah have a
good rest of your evening have a good
day tomorrow
and we will see you guys again on friday
night bye
about you but i'm hungry